Bonsoir,
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. On vous reçoit dans le
cadre de votre activité autour de la
science, l'écologie, l'économie et même
la politique pour vous. Pierre
Larutorou. On va commencer par
Jean-Josel. Jean-Jousel, est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement s'il
vous plaît ? Oui, c'est exactement.
Bien, j'ai consacré toute ma vie à
disons à la recherche en fait. Je suis
chercheur sur l'évolution du climat et
j'ai commencé il y a une cinquantaine
d'années mais depuis je m'intéresse
aussi au climat mais aussi disons aux
aspects aux conséquences de ce
réchauffement climatique et aux aspects
sociétaux. Je suis par exemple membre du
conseil économique social
environnemental.
Euh je m'intéresse aussi au disons au
lien avec les décisions politiques. Donc
ça va au-delà de la simple travail de
recherche mais c'est au cœur quand même
de mes activités. La recherche est au
cœur de mes activités.
Vous êtes cététenteur du prix Nobel de
la paix.
Donc on a eu Oui. Enfin c'est le GC.
Donc j'étais vice-président du groupe
scientifique en 2007 au moment où le GC
a eu a partagé le prix Nobel de la paix,
le groupe intervenental d'experts sur
l'évolution du climat. donc à partager
le prix Nobel de la paix avec Algor.
Voilà. Donc c'était c'est très important
parce que cette idée du prix Nobel de la
paix, c'est vraiment que si nous ne
faisons rien pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique,
ça sera difficile d'espérer un, je
dirais un développement harmonieux
civilisation et si on veut faire quelque
chose, il faut être solidaire. Donc
c'est ça le le sens de ce prix Nobel de
la paix. Je veux dire, il faut vraiment
cette solidarité ou sinon et bien euh je
nous allons dans le mur. Je ne suis pas
du tout psologue mais vraiment un
développement harmonieux de nos
civilisations serait très difficile.
Pierre la route roue, [grognement]
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Oui, je voudrais en
rajouter sur Jean parce qu'il est trop
modeste pour le dire mais Jean Joselle
et Claude Lorius sont à et puis ou de
d'autres chercheurs sont à l'origine des
découverte fondamental qui parce qu' ont
montré le lien entre le CO2 et le
dérèglement climatique. C'était il y a
34 ans ou 35 ans leur article qui montre
qu'ils avaient analysé une carotte de
glace. Il y en a qui étaient le pôle
sud. Ils avaient analysé la glace sur
180000 ans. Ils ont analysé le gaz qui
était enfermé là depuis 180000 ans et la
et ils ont [raclement de gorge] montré
le lien avec le réchauffement climatique
et leur courbe était tellement évidente
que tout le monde en a parlé à travers
la planète alors que d'habitude des
articles dans Nature, il y a pas grand
monde qui en parle et que du coup
quelques temps plus tard Ronald Rean,
Margarette Satcher ont été obligés de
créer le JC parce qu'on voyait bien
qu'il y avait un énorme problème. Donc
c'est Jean est trop modeste pour le dire
mais tu es vraiment un très très grand
chercheur, un gars adorable, un ancien
footballeur mais un très très grand
chercheur. Et puis ça veut dire quand
même que ça fait 35 ans en gros qu'on
sait qu'il y a un problème. Voilà. Et et
on ne fait rien. Voilà.
Et vous voulez pas vous présenter ?
Si si, je n'ai rien à cacher. Je
m'appelle Pierre Larouturou. Je suis
ingénieur agronome. J'ai failli être
chercheur mais je ne l'ai pas été. Donc
depuis très longtemps, je m'intéresse à
l'avenir de la planète. J'étais un élève
de René René Dumont, le premier candidat
écolo et j'ai eu la chance d'aller donc
qu'il me raconte sa vie tout ce qu'il
avait fait au Burkina Faso en Inde ou
ailleurs. Donc ça fait très longtemps
que je m'intéresse à l'avenir de la
planète et puis on travaille avec
Jean-Jousel avec Michel Rocard et
Stéphan Essel. En 2012, on avait déjà
lancé l'idée d'un pacte européen pour
pour agir vraiment sur le climat et la
biodiversité et puis depuis 2 ans, on a
intensifié nos efforts avec Jean et avec
quelques autres.
On va commencer par une question
qui n'est pas tout de suite technique
pour éviter de de gaver nos auditeurs.
Je voudrais avoir votre avis sur ce qui
se passe autour de Greta Thonberg.
Je voudrais avoir votre avis sur la
levée de bouclier du gouvernement
concernant Greta Tonberg. Je voudrais
votre avis sur la levée de de bouclier
de certains scientifiques ou médecins
qui qui tapent sur Greta Tenberg.
Jean-Joelle. Oui, de façon très claire,
moi je disons je pense que c'est
important d'avoir Gretenberg.
Il me r même de dire que parce qu'on
pose souvent la question pourquoi je
répète les mêmes choses depuis comme l'a
dit Pierre depuis une trentaine d'années
ou depuis les années 80.
Vous pleurez jamais vous ? Non, je
disons non, mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi le
une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
n'avons pas été écoutés peut-être que
nous n'avons pas eu du Gretatenberg au
début des années 2000 au moment du
protocole de Kyoto. Voilà donc je pense
que c'est important que la mobilisation
des jeunes que disons la disons dans
laquelle Greta Tunberg a joué dans
lequel Greta Tunberg a joué un rôle
extrêmement important et pour moi très
porteuse d'avenir. Donc je pense et ce
que dit Gretenberg quand on dit qu'elle
est catastrophiste,
la seule référence qu'elle fasse c'est
vraiment écouter les scientifiques donc
et je crois qu'elle s'y tient. Donc
personnellement je suis très attaché et
on voit bien enfin disons que le
bon on a un scientifique ce soir.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'elle redoute Greta
Tonberg ? Bien justement, elle redoute
que si nous ne faisons rien pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique, elle
le dit, elle le redit. Et c'est ce que
nous disons notre communauté
scientifique. Et bien nous allons
versements qui peuvent être très
importants à la fin du siècle. 4 à 5°gr
euh voire peut-être en plus, mais disons
même 4 à 5°gr, c'est vraiment un monde
différent. C'est ce dont les les gens
doivent se rendre compte. Quand on parle
de réchauffement climatique, on a le
sentiment que c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui. Mais c'est pas du tout ça.
Le réchauffement climatique tel qu'il
serait si rien n'était fait pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique,
c'est un autre monde. Je me souviens il
y a il y a une vingtaine d'années quand
on quand je disais ça m'arrivait de dire
que et bien un jour assez assez
rapidement en France on aura des records
de température qui seront supérieurs à
45°gr. Les gens souriaent, c'est très
clair. Les gens disaient caus toujours
et maintenant bien voilà, on en est là
et on peut penser malheureusement que
dès les années 2050 2060 et bien si on
continue nous aurons, on pourrait avoir
en France des records de température
jusqu'à 50°. Donc c'est un autre monde
et donc on peut parler de nous et encore
nous sommes privilégiés en France.
Comment vous expliquez que qu'on tape
sur Greta Thonberg ? Vous pensez qu'il y
a des lobby de l'industrie derrière ?
Non, mais moi je qui les qu'est-ce qui
motive les gens à dire qu'elle est
catastrophiste, que la science et la
technologie nous ont toujours sauvé, que
ça crée une génération dépressif,
c'est on on lui on lui objecte ça. On
lui objecte qu'elle devrait les soigner,
qu'elle devrait prendre des petites
pilules, retourner à l'école. Oui, ben
moi je simplement me référer à un
éditorial de Stéphane Fouard dans le
monde il y a pendant quelques semaines
et bien chefar dit c'est c'est cela les
gens qui ne veulent rien faire. D'abord
il y a eu le climatoscepticisme. Ensuite
il voit qu'ils n'ont plus d'arguments et
maintenant la seule façon pour eux de
réagir vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe
c'est de taper sur Katreta Tunberg. On
en est là. C'est-à-dire que ceux qui ce
n'est pas ce sont des disons il y a il y
a différents courants. On peut même pas
dire qu'il y a un lobby. Mais c'est ceux
qui ne veulent rien faire. Ils veulent
bien en parler mais ils ne veulent rien
faire. On peut voir par exemple Nicolas
Sarkozi, il a été et enfin moi j'ai
travaillé avec lui enfin disons à
l'époque du du grenel de l'environnement
mais malheureusement il a abandonné
disons son célèbre l'environnement ça
suffit évidemment ça a marqué la fin du
du de la dynamique du grenet de
l'environnement donc on voit bien ces
gens donc c'est parce que simplement ils
veulent pas que les choses se passent
ils veulent fermer les yeux et
franchement c'est bien là c'est disons
c'est presque un réflexe de désespéré
parce que euh voilà et donc il y a il y
a pas vraiment d'argument. Euh bon, je
le fait que Greta Thberg soit dans un
environnement effectivement avec lequel
elle discute et qu'elle est qu'elle soit
aidée dans ce bien sûr, elle lit aussi,
on l'aide à je crois à euh disons elle
elle est elle est elle est bien sûr euh
je je dirais qu'elle a elle a elle est
bien entourée, elle est bien disons du
point de vue scientifique, c'est clair
que celle qu'elle avance est vraiment
généralement très correcte. J'ai jamais
vu avancer quelque chose d'incorrect.
dire que bien oui, il faut bah d'une
certaine façon nous sommes aussi
catastrophistes nous enfin mais
simplement il suffit de lire la rapport
du siècle et c'est ce qu'elle nous
invite à faire. C'est une catastrophe si
on ne fait rien pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique.
On reviendra au rapport du G. C'est très
important. Il vient de sortir il y a pas
très longtemps le nouveau euh Pierre
Laroutou. Le fait qu'on essaie de
psychiatriser Greta Tunberg, qu'on
essaie de la faire passer pour quelqu'un
de dépressif, quelqu'un qui devrait
retourner à l'école ou quelqu'un qui par
exemple quand elle dit "Vous allez me
gâcher mon enfance" alors que il y a il
y a des petits enfants qui sont à quatre
pattes dans les risières pour aller
ramasser du riz ou qui portent des des
des tonneaux de flott en Afrique. Euh
mais moi j'ai honte tous ceux qui
critiquent Gret Tonberg, j'ai
franchement honte. euh les députés
français qui se sont moqués d'elle, ils
auraient juste dû prendre 1 heure pour
aller l'écouter ou qu'il prennent 1
heure pour écouter Jean-Josel ou pour
lire les rapports du chèque. C'est
franchement un aveuglement qui est
ridicule et c'est et s'il y a
effectivement des gens qui dépriment,
j'ai un ami en Belgique dont la fille a
essayé de se suicider tellement elle est
inquiète pour la lumière de la planète
mais c'est pas à cause de Greta, c'est
juste l'inaction de nos dirigeants. Il y
a 30 ans déjà qu'on a créé le GC parce
qu'il y avait une évidence. Tout le
monde dit qu'on a plus que quelques
années pour pour agir. Gutérèz, le
patron de Loinu, dit qu'on a plus que 2
ans pour agir. Il y a des cercles, la
plupart de nos politiques ne comprennent
rien aux sciences, sont très sûrs d'eux.
Ils ont fait les meilleures écoles, ils
pensent qu'ils ont tout compris avant
tout le monde et ils ont l'habitude de
gérer des problèmes linéaires. On arrive
au pouvoir, on met quelques rustines et
puis on laissera le bazar à jour. Si
vous voulez réir en même temps, vous
pouvez hein.
Oui. Non mais je
Pierre a raison qu'il faut bon
voilà c'est pas c'est pas Greta
Thundberg qui est en cause, c'est
vraiment les gens qui critiquent Greta
Thunberg qui qui doivent être mis en
cause dans leur propre raisonnement et
dans leur propre attitude. C'est très
clair pour moi et donc ça l' aussi pour
Pierre et je pense que les exemples sont
là. Ce n'est pas ce n'est pas non plus
en en disant en masquant l'avenir qu'on
va entraîner les jeunes vers l'action.
C'est ça que nous devons faire et que
nous souhaitons faire collectivement.
euh avec disons voilà donc on a beaucoup
à faire Pierre dans sa disons dans là
aussi maintenant peut-être plus avec une
démarche politique, je le fais toujours
du point de vue plus scientifique mais
voilà l'objectif est l'action ce n'est
pas du tout l'inaction comme les disons
ceux qui s'élèvent contre Greta Tenberg
en sont les les porteurs réellement
d'inaction porteur Greta a compris l'un
des messages fondamentaux des
scientifiques, c'est dire on va vers un
point d'effondrement, on va vers un
point de non retour je sais pas si on
peut voir cette courbe, c'est
l'évolution de la glace au Groenland, la
fonte des glaces au Groenlande depuis 40
ans. Avril, mai, juin, juillet, en
moyenne, depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans, à la
fin de l'été, quand il avait fait très
chaud, il y avait 20 % de la glace qui a
fondu. 20 %. Cette année, au mois de
juin, il y avait 45 % de la glace qui a
fondue. Le problème n'est pas linéaire.
On sait tous que une surface blanche,
elle va renvoyer la lumière et la
chaleur. Qu truc est foncé, il va
absorber la chaleur. Donc quand le
réchauffement climatique fait fondre la
glace et moins il y a de glace, plus on
va se réchauffer. Le réchauffement
climatique fait fondre le permafroste.
Le permafrost, il se décongèle et il
envoie du méthane dans l'atmosphère qui
est 14 fois plus grave que le CO2. Le
réchauffement climatique fait que les
feux de forêt depuis 10 ans en
Californie, là ça a été multiplié par 4,
il y a quatre fois plus de feux de forêt
qu' a 50 ans. Donc tous les imbéciles,
je reste poli mais tous les imbéciles
qui nous dirigent et qui pensent que il
faut que Greta prenne sa pilule et
qu'elle se calme un peu, ils n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont réellement pas pris une
heure pas pris une heure pour réfléchir
et ils n'ont pas compris non plus que ça
pourrait être une opportunité que si on
met le paquet sur la transition
écologique, on pourrait créer 5 millions
d'emplois en Europe. On pourrait
respirer un air qui est meilleur pour
notre santé. On pourrait avoir une une
alimentation meilleure pour nous. On
pourrait faire des économies. L'autre
jour, j'étais à Grenoble dans une cité
de HLM qui a été isolée et le monsieur
qui m'accueit disait "Viment depuis
qu'on a isolé mon bâtiment, j'ai
beaucoup moins chaud l'été, j'ai
beaucoup moins froid l'hiver et
j'économise 800 € chaque année." C'était
pas un climatologue ou un économiste,
c'était un gars qui vit là depuis des
années qui dit "On a isolé le bâtiment,
j'y gagne en qualité de vie et j'y gagne
800 €." Et pardon, le maire de Grenoble
disait, j'aimerais en faire plus mais je
n'ai pas les moyens financiers et c'est
pour ça qu'on se bat pour un pacte
climat au niveau européen qui donne les
moyens pour accélérer. Jean Jean euh euh
là le nouveau rapport du JC est sorti,
le nouveau rapport du JC' tarde un peu
plus sur les océans.
On parle des océans de de canicules
océaniques, des des vêtements très
chauds sur certaines régions du globe
qui pour être pour parler très
trivialement fait crever tout ce qui se
trouve au-dessus de la thermocline et
et qui vont se multiplier. Oui, c'est
et qui vont se multiplier. Et aussi
alors j'en suis pas arrivé alors
peut-être que vous l'avez pas encore
traité parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas
excusez-moi la totalité de votre
rapport. Est-ce que vous parlez des
hydrates de de carbone qui pètent sous
les mers ?
Non, pas trop. Enfin, pas dans ce
rapport. Il y a pas il y a pas il y a
pas disons quand on parle de d'hydrate,
il y a il y a quand même de risque sur
disons sous la mer. Donc effectivement,
il y a il y a deux façons d'avoir du
méthane dans les sols gelées. C'est de
la matière organique et aussi à disons
les premières épaisseurs de sédiments
marins. Mais pour que ça se réchauffe au
fond, généralement non, on névoque pas
beaucoup les problèmes d'hydrate dans
ces casl. Est-ce que est-ce que vous en
avez discuté avec les ingénieurs de chez
Total ou les ingénieurs qui travaillent
dans la dans la prospection sous-marine
ou avec certains gouvernements qui
s'inquiétaent
d'entendre sur leur capteur de grosses
détonations ? qui pensait que c'était
des des détonations d'armes nucléaires
surtout surtout vers l'article.
Oui, sur ce point-là, je pense que c'est
il y a toujours eu des effectivement des
des désintégrations. Donc l'hydrate de
méthane, ce disons ces événements ont
toujours ont toujours existé. Il y a
toujours eu du du méthane qui qui s'est
probablement formé à juste à à
l'interface sédiment entre sédiment et
le fond disons le fond des des eaux
océaniques. Mais euh je disons la
difficulté actuellement qu'on a c'est de
savoir si ça s'accélère ou non. Donc le
fait que on l'entende et qu'il y ait
qu'il y en est actuellement ne veut pas
dire que ça s'accélère. Donc pour le
moment il y a pas il y a pas vraiment je
dirais de panique par rapport à ces de
méthan. On peut quand même voir que il y
a 50 millions d'années, il est très
probable que c'est des ces hydrates de
méthane qui ont été à l'origine d'un
d'un réchauffement relativement rapide.
Donc ça a existé dans les passés
géologiques. Il faut être très attentif
mais c'est vrai que en terme de
production de méthane supplémentaire on
est plus inquiet enfin notre communauté
est plus inquiète par rapport à la fonte
des soldes gelés disons en Sibérie ou
dans l'article canadien
et par notre consommation et par notre
modèle agriculture pardon. C'est c'est
de loin. C'est de loin et ça c'est aussi
une des points qu'il faut souligner. Euh
bien sûr, il y a du méthane qui va
sortir des sols gelé. Mais avant tout la
première la première contribution, ça
reste nos activités. Il ne faut pas
cacher euh notre rôle derrière des
phénomènes qu'on pourrait ne pas
maîtriser en disant effectivement la
nature elle-même va générer son propre
métal. Non, je suis en train de dire
simplement les océans se réchauffent.
Comme les océans se réchauffent, ça
réchauffe les hydrates. Donc ça pète.
Pour le moment, il y a pas il y a pas
dans dans ce rapport disons de cri
d'alarme par rapport à cette formation
d'hydrate. Dans le dernier rapport du
GC, on disait aussi que ce n'était pas
enfin disons qu'il y avait relativement
peu de risque. C'est l'état actuel de de
notre science. On verra bien sûr si
l'océan de de disons si l'océan profond
se réchauffait de façon importante, il y
a ce risque qui deviendrait plus
prignant.
Revenons sur l'état des glaces. Euh vous
en parlez dans votre rapport. euh un
petit un petit tour d'horizon
un petit tour d'horizon de ce qui se
passe actuellement. Bon, je pense que si
on regarde alors c'était bien dans ce
rapport de regarder à la fois l'océan et
la cryosphère, les glaces, l'océan et
les glaces. Pourquoi ? Bien parce que un
des principaux dangers de l'océan, c'est
quand même l'élévation du niveau de la
mer. L'élévation du niveau de la mer
actuellement, c'est de l'ordre d'un peu
plus de 3 mm chaque année. Ça c'est
accéléré, hein, c'est pratiquement deux
fois plus rapide qu'il y a une centaine
d'années ou 50 ans même. Et donc 3 mm
chaque année, en fait 1 mm lié à peu
près 1 mm lié à au réchauffement de
l'océan. L'océan se réchauffe, il se
dilate. Et puis pratiquement l'essentiel
du reste lié à la fonte des glaces à peu
près en disons en trois parties à le
Groenland. Euh moi quand j'étais quand
on a commencé
euh euh disons il y a une vingtaine
d'années ou une trentaine d'années, on
nous disait que le Grenland était à
l'équilibre, c'est-à-dire queen gros il
ne perdait pas de glace de de volume et
depuis une vingtaine d'années,
visiblement il en perd. Ça contribue
aussi pour avec l'Antarctique, ça
contribue pratiquement pour la moitié
d'élévation du niveau de la mer chaque
année. Puis il y a une partie aussi liée
à la fonte des glaciers continentaux.
Ceux des Alpes, ça joue pas beaucoup
mais l'Himalaya, les Indes, les glaciers
d'Alaska. Donc disons, on a vraiment
dans ce dans cette élévation du niveau
de la mer un double indicateur du
réchauffement climatique à travers le
réchauffement de l'océan et bien sûr la
fonte des glaces. Mais pour le moment,
c'est un indicateur, ça a déjà des
conséquences sur disons ça peut
accélérer le le enfin l'érosion dans
certains endroits, mais ce qui nous
attend c'est vraiment terrible
[raclement de gorge] si on ne fait rien
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique. C'est cela en terme de
d'élévation du niveau de la mer, de
fondre des glaces. C'est ce vers quoi
nous allons. Ce vers quoi nous allons,
c'est quand même probablement 1 m si on
ne fait rien d'ici la fin du siècle
d'élévation du niveau de la mer, des
villes, des grandes villes qui seraient
vraiment mises à mises en difficulté. On
peut penser de New York, on peut Tokyo,
Calcuta, Bombet bien sûr, Daka, mais euh
Bangkok.
Ouais. Donc il y a des il y a des
régions en France. Non mais en France
c'est on est on est on est disons la
Camargue en France disons, il y a des
régions.
Est-ce que vous parlez de la
salinisation des sols ?
Oui, bien sûr. Ça c'est un des deux
autres points parce que les eaux
pénètrent, l'élévation du niveau de la
mer se traduit par une salinisation des
sols dans les régions côtières. Et ça
c'est extrêmement ou extrêmement négatif
par rapport à l'agriculture. C'est sold
de disons perdre leur productivité. Et
donc il y a il y a beaucoup d'effets
d'élévation du niveau de la mer. Ils
sont quand même tous négatifs en terme
de de protection des infrastructures.
De plus en plus certains pays pensent à
redonner à redonner des terres à la mer.
Et donc il faut il faut bien comprendre
qu'on en est rendu là dans certaines
régions. Il ne sera pas possible de de
protéger des des grandes villes contre
un voire 2 m. C'est plutôt 3 m à la fin
du siècle prochain. Donc ces
infrastructures sont toujours là et puis
c'est rien n'est fait pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique. C'est la
fonte du Groenland d'chéance de quelques
siècles et là ce sont 7 m
supplémentaires d'élévation.
Une dernière question pour vous Jean.
Est-ce que vous parlez des chaînes de
volcan en Antarctique qui pourraient se
réactiver parce que l'Antarctique
perdrait de sa calotte glaciaire ?
Là pas non plus dans ce rapport mais
l'Antarctique ne perdra pas enfin
l'Antarctique de l'Est. C'est cette
chaîne, elle est entre entre
l'Antarctique de l'Ouest et
l'Antarctique de l'Est largement des
montagnes transntarctiques justement.
Mais non, le disons le heureusement
l'Antarctique c'est 60 m d'élévation du
niveau de la mer. Il y a une partie de
l'Antarctique l'Antarctique de l'Ouest
où il y a 4 à 5 m d'élévation du niveau
de la mer. Bon, c'est ce disons proche
de l'Amérique du Sud cette partie-là. Et
bien et bien là, elle elle est elle est
plus fragile. Mais l'Antarctique de
l'Est, disons ça, c'est sont près de 60
m d'élévation des niveaux de la mer est
quand même très froid. Il y a pas de
fusion dans les régions dans les régions
côtières, ce qui n'est pas le cas au
Groenland, hein. Donc, on voit bien
cette fusion dans les régions côtières.
Il y en a pas dans l'Est parce qu'il
fait quand même - 20 disons des
températures trop froides. Donc non, il
y a il y a pas il y a pas de de enfin
bien sûr si l'Antarctique fondait mais
ça n'arrivera pas à échéance prévisible
ça jourait évidemment ça libère hein
bien sûr on a vu ça d'ailleurs là aussi
dans le passé le fait d'avoir une
calotte glaciaère qui qui libère des des
contraintes peut effectivement être à
l'origine d'un volcanisme plus
important.
Pierre, c'est ça me paraît très sexy
comme programme [grognement]
la réponse des politiques je rajouter
pardon parce que pardon non non mais à
votre demande Jean vient de parler du
dernier rapport mais moi je suis pas
climatologue mais je j'ai passé de jours
à Bamaako il y a quelques temps au Mali
et il vous explique tout le monde s'en
fout mais que la sécheresse que vit le
Sahel en ce moment on n jamais vu une
telle sécheresse. C'est voilà en Inde
l'été dernier gens a dit qu'on avait des
cannicules en France on a eu 45°gr hein.
et en Inde, il a fait 50°gr. On nous
explique que il y a plusieurs grandes
villes d'Inde qui dans 4 ou 5 ans
n'auront plus une goutte d'eau dans la
nappe fratique. Donc évidemment, il le
dernier rapport est très sérieux quand
on dit que l'eau va monter de 1 m et
qu'il y a des villes qui vont être
submergées dans 30 ans, 40 ans, 50 ans
parce que c'est pas linéaire, il y a des
voilà mais je pense qu' il faut vraiment
dire et on revient à la question de
Greta elle a raison de dire qu'on a plus
que quelques années pour agir et que
sinon de notre vivant de notre vivant on
va connaître la barbarie. Quand l'ONU
annonce 150 millions de réfugiés
climatiques dans 30 ans, 150 millions
d'hommes et de femmes qui auront le
choix entre crever sur place ou essayer
de bouger pour essayer de survivre. À
Bamako, il parle du sida climatique. Le
vrai sida, le VIH, le virus du sida a
fait des dizaines de milliers de morts
en Afrique. Mais ils disent que le
climat va faire autant de milliers de
morts et les gens auront le choix entre
mourir sur place ou bouger. Quand l'ONU
dit qu'il y en a 90 millions qui devront
quitter l'Afrique, ils vont vouloir
traverser la Méditerranée. Donc c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles
l'Europe devrait agir avec force. C'est
pour ça qu'on se bat avec Jean et avec
d'autres pour un pact européen en disant
il s'agit pas de se flageller, il s'agit
juste de dire la vérité. Si on fait le
bilan depuis 2 siècle, premièrement
l'Europe est la première puissance
économique mondiale et depuis 2 siècles,
c'est nous qui sommes le plus gros
émetteurs de CO2. Maintenant, c'est la
Chine ou les États-Unis, mais le bilan
depuis de siècle, c'est nous. Donc, nous
avons la responsabilité de C'est trop
facile de se moquer de Trump. Quand on
revient quand Merkel et Macron
reviennent de New York et disent à cause
de Trump, on peut rien faire, c'est du
pipo. L'Europe a tous les moyens d'agir
sur son territoire et de financer un
vrai plan marchal pour l'Afrique.
Est-ce que vous vous deux, est-ce que
vous défendez l'idée d'un statut spécial
pour les réfugiés climatiques et est-ce
que vous avez perçu comme nous que ça il
y avait pas beaucoup d'éch dans le
milieu politique et scientifique ? Donc
moi, je me suis intéressé, j'ai préfacé
un livre sur la réfugié climatique. Euh
voilà, donc il y a quelques années, on a
beaucoup mais ça n'a pas beaucoup
progressé. Effectivement, certaines
disons certaines personnes euh se
battent pour un statut de réfugié. Euh
donc ça serait important. On voit bien
que les pays s'y opposent parce qu'à
partir du moment où il y aurait ce
statut de réfugié, effectivement, ils
ont peur de façon très claire, voilà. Ou
ou même en Europe, il y a pas il y a pas
du tout il y a pas un soutien très fort
pour donner un statut à ces réfugiés
climatiques parce que bon voilà. Donc il
son ça veut dire statut, ça veut dire
aussi obligation d'accueillir. On voit
bien que quand on parle de alors de
dizaines de millions certainement,
peut-être une centaine de millions, ça
dépend l'échéance à laquelle on se place
évidemment, c'est aussi toute l'accueil
qui est derrière et donc non, je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de pays
qui soutiennent. Alors évidemment quand
on parle de l'Australie là, il y a il y
a eu carrément un refus par rapport à
disons des petites îles parce que des
petites îles commence déjà à penser
aller s'établir autre part. Mais oui,
moi je crois je suis donc assez
favorable à ce à ce statut mais ça ne
progresse pas beaucoup actuellement me
semble-t-il.
On a vraiment des dirigeantes. Je ne
veux pas juger les personnes. J'adorais
Vaclav et Vaclavel disait le rôle du
citoyen n'est pas de juger les
politiques mais de dire la vérité. Et
honnête
Check Lavavel Tèck un grand homme de
théâtre et qui tout d'un coup s'est
engagé. Il est un de ceux qui a fait que
des millions de gens sont engagés pour
faire tomber le mur de Berlin. Il disait
le rôle n'est pas de juger les
politiques mais de dire la vérité. Et
honnêtement je suis d'accord avec Greta
pour dire mais on vous en voudra à mort.
Et je pense que je on on a toutes les
preuves. Maintenant je le répète si le
GC a été créé il y a 30 ans par Ronald
Regan Margaret Tatcher, c'était pas des
écolos, c'est qu'il y avait déjà une
évidence. Il y a un bouquin qui vient de
sortir qui montre comment déjà en 79, il
y a un rapport qui a été remis à la
Maison Blanche par les plus grands
scientifiques américains. C'était pas
trois rigolo qui avaient bu un café
ensemble. C'était le conseiller
scientifique de Kennedy, le conseiller
scientifique de Johnson qui avait bossé
avec plein de climatologues et qui ont
rendu en 79 un rapport pour dire on va
vers un dérèglement climatique dû à
l'activité humaine et quand ce sera une
évidence pour tout le monde, ce sera
trop tard pour agir. Et le problème
c'est qu'à ce moment-là, quand il y a un
consensus scientifique, c'était peu de
temps avant que vous apportiez la preuve
physique de du réchauffement et du lien
avec le CO2. Et le problème c'est que
Ronald Rean arrive à la Maison Blanche
quelques mois plus tard et avec Ronald
Rean, il y a tous les lobby du pétrole
qui font tout pour dire peut-être que
oui, peut-être que non et malgré ça
après ça Rigan accepte le GC mais on met
voilà donc on a perdu 40 ans et
maintenant ça devient absolument
scandaleux qu'on n'est pas capable
d'agir donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
qu'on pousse. Tuétais l'autre jour avec
trop tard.
Non c'est pas trop tard. C'est avec
l'inertie de ce système.
Non non, justement quand quand Perbord
quand il y a si on a une volonté
politique, on peut faire bouger les
choses. Quand Kennedy dit on va aller
sur la Lune, il y en a qui pensent qu'il
est frappe à dingue et qu'il a pris un
coup de soleil parce qu'elle est sur la
Lune c'est juste impossible. Mais
Kennedy met les moyens, le budget de la
NASA va être multiplié par 15. Je pense
qu'il y a des comptables qui ont fait
des crises cardiaques. On multiplie par
15 le budget de la NASA. On crée 400000
emplois.
C'était 3 % du PIB américain.
On crée 400000 emplois. Le technicien
est de l'autre côté de la caméra. Le
vrai expert se cache. On crée 400000
emplois et on va sur la Lune plus vite
que prévu. Quand les Japonais bombardent
la perle Harbor, en 3 mois, toute
l'économie américaine se transforme.
Roosevelt décide qu'on va rentrer en
guerre et c'est une transformation
totale. Des entreprises qui faisaient
des voitures ne vont plus faire une
seule voiture et vont se transformer
pour pour aider à l'économie de guerre.
Mais mais le schéma était le même.
C'était un schéma de consommation dans
une croissance exponentielle qui a été
qui a été reuté, refléché pour aller sur
une politique guerrière. OK, mais c'est
je pardon la Ber ce que je veux dire
c'est que quand il y a une volonté
politique quand Jules Ferry décide de
faire l'école pour tous, il y en a qui
pensent qu'il est qu'il est fou que
c'est une idée généreuse mais que le
pays n'a pas les moyens qu'on a encore
besoin des enfants dans les usines et
dans les et dans les dans les fermes. Il
y a une pression des citoyens. J'ai
découvert récemment que par la ligue de
l'enseignement était créée à l'époque
pour dire à Jul Ferry allez-y, on compte
sur vous. Il y a eu 1200000 citoyens qui
ont signé la pétition pour demander
l'école laïque gratuite et obligatoire.
À l'époque, il y avait pas internet. On
voit les carioles qui remontent vers
Paris avec 1200000 pétitions pour dire
on veut cette école gratuite laïque qui
est obligatoire et Jules Ferry en
quelques années met les moyens
financiers et on est capable de réussir
ça. Donc nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il
n'est pas trop tard pour agir qu'on peut
encore l'Europe doit doit faire le on
l'excuse Trump ne veut rien faire n'est
pas une excuse en Europe. L'excuse je
suis maintenant député européen depuis 3
mois l'excuse avec Urban c'est compliqué
c'est du pipot. L'autre jour, j'étais à
Madrid avec le conseiller de Pedro
Sanchez et il me disait "Tu n'as pas
besoin de l'unanimité. L'unanimité, on
se fait plaisir pour dire en fait même
s'il y a que 12 ou 14 pays qui veulent
agir vraiment sur le climat, on peut le
faire. On appelle ça une coopération
renforcée. Mais du point de vue
juridique, même s'il y a neuf pays
seulement qui veulent avancer et tant
pis si monsieur Urban n'a rien à faire,
son pays suivra plus tard. Donc
maintenant, et c'est pour ça que je suis
très heureux à Bruxelles de voir toutes
les grandes manifes, les amis de Greta
en Belgique, c'est Adélaï, Anouna et
d'autres. Et toutes les semaines, il y a
des manifestations. Dimanche, elles
étaient près du parlement et elles
disent "Mais arrêtez les discours
maintenant, on veut passer à l'action."
Vous cautionnez le fait que les gamin
n'aillent pu à l'école le weekend le le
en fin de semaine ?
Oui, enfin je regarde ça avec avec
intérêt. Je bon je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
pris position par rapport à ça. Bon, je
préfère aller au march climat le samedi.
J'aimerais bien aussi que les jeunes y
viennent mais c'était difficile samedi
dernier effectivement. Mais ce que je
veux dire, c'est que et je l'ai déjà dit
aux jeunes, c'est que cette mobilisation
leur a déjà apporté beaucoup. Euh quand
on regarde les programmes disons de les
programmes euh d'abord en premier lieu,
les programmes de qui seront enseignés
en au lycée et bien euh disons si on le
regarde en début d'année, il n'y avait
pratiquement rien sur le développement
durable, sur le réchauffement climatique
et depuis ces programmes ont été
modifiés, enrichi en fait le tron
commun, dans le trop commun, il y aura
un nombre d'heures relativement
important dédié à au réchauffement
climatique, à la biodiversité Et euh
c'est grâce à disons à à des gens comme
Pierre Lena, comme Valérie Masson
Delmote, mais aussi euh à la
mobilisation des jeunes. Et maintenant,
disons cette semaine, enfin disons j'ai
été auditionné par le Conseil supérieur
des programmes parce que Jean-Michel
Blanquer a invité le Conseil supérieur
des programmes à réfléchir à ce qui
pouvait être fait non pas simplement au
lycée mais de la maternelle à la 3è he
donc dans le domaine du réchauffement
climatique de la de la biodiversité du
développement durable et c'est très
clair que sans la mobilisation des
jeunes si cela est arrivé c'est-à-dire
Jean-Michel Blanquire a accepté de
réfléchir à au programme, de les
reprendre, et bien c'est grâce à la
mobilisation des jeunes. Il faut bien se
rendre compte que cette mobilisation des
jeunes a eu un effet déjà extrêmement
important. C'est pour cela qu'il faut
effectivement que les jeunes prennent
conscience. Les jeunes doivent prendre
conscience au lycée. Donc la façon de
prendre conscience peut-être diverse
mais c'est vrai aussi à l'université, il
y a le manifeste des 15000 disons en
terme de là aussi où les les gens des
enfin des jeunes des grandes écoles et
des universités disent que vraiment
l'enseignement ce qu'on leur enseigne
n'est pas du tout adapté par rapport à
ce vers quoi ils veulent aller. C'est un
peu le message qu'il donne. Donc ces
jeunes sont là et je pense que la
mobilisation des jeunes est très
importante et a déjà eu des effets.
Pierre, est-ce qu'il faut passer à une
mobilisation euh un peu moins euh tiède,
c'est-à-dire certains certains
activistes euh prêche
une manifestation ou une prise de
conscience plus violente, plus
opérationnelle, plus
du même type qu'une guerria.
Alors, violence.
Est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut
cautionner ça ? Est-ce que c'est une
réalité ? C'est-à-dire c'est une guerre
et il faut prendre les mesures pour il
faut faire quoi ?
Alors juste une minute pour appuyer ce
que disait Jean sur l'utilité des
manifes étudiantes. On était l'autre
jour en débat avec Nicolas Hul à
Bruxelles et il y avait au premier rang
le ministre Wallon du budget Jean-Luc
Cruc qui disait que c'était grâce aux
manifestations d'étudiants. Ça le climat
ça l'intéressait mais c'est quand il a
vu tout ce monde dans la rue y compris
ses enfants, les copains des les enfants
des copains qui il a dit il a il nous a
dit qu'il avait lu en une nuit le petit
bouquin qu'on a fait avec Jean-Josel et
Anessel. Voilà, qui l'avait lu en une
nuit qui pensait que tous les chiffres
étaient faux. Il a raconté ça en public
qui a fait vérifier par le ministère que
c'était vrai et il dit maintenant on
fait une coalition et à part l'extrême
droite, on rassemble tout le monde
autour de ce projet. Et ça y est, depuis
2 semaines en Walloni, il y a un accord
des trois parties. Ils ont 15
propositions mais dans une des
propositions c'est de porter ce pacte
climat au niveau européen. Et ça c'est
parce que les amis de Greta Adélaï,
Anouna et les autres étaient toutes les
semaines dans la rue. Et moi j'ai dit à
mes fistons qu'ils avaient le droit de
sécher les cours de temps en temps pour
aller dans ces manifes. Tous les moyens
non violents de la pression et de
dire la vérité et de dire maintenant on
accélère, on arrête le discours, on
passe à l'action sont bon. sur d'autres
méthodes. Je pense effectivement, j'ai
vu le film Anita que voilà, je pense
qu'on se rend compte que ce qu'on fait
n'est pas suffisant, que ça fait 30 ans
que le JC améliore encore ses ses
évaluations, ça fait des 30 ans qu'il y
a des ONG qui disent "Attention, faut
accélérer." Et manifestement, pour le
moment, il faut qu'on soit modeste. Nous
n'avons pas trouvé le moyen de mettre en
mouvement nos dirigeants. Donc ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut passer dans la
violence. Je pense que dès qu'on arrive
à la violence, c'est contre-productif.
Moi, je me suens à Notre-Dame des
Landes. Une fois, j'avais fait une
manife à Notre-Dame des Landes. On était
des dizaines de milliers, c'était super
joyeux, pas un gram de violence. Et puis
il y a cinq casseurs et je peux dire
qu'il y avait des CRS à proximité mais
que c'est à l'époque où Manuel Valtait
aux manettes. On a laissé les casseurs
cassés et alors qu'on aurait très bien
pu les choper et les mettre à l'écart.
Et après ça, ça a complètement dégénéré.
Les images de télévision, le soir,
c'était que des casseurs. On s'est pris
des lacrymogènes. Ce jour-là, on était
au moins 20000 dans la rue et il y a un
sondage qui disait que 80 % des gens ne
voulaient pas d'un deuxième aéroport.
Mais à cause des casseurs, on a retenu
dans toutes les émission télé que la
violence et du coup la fois suivante les
gens avaient la trouille d'aller dans la
manif. Donc je pense que les actions
violentes ne sont pas la solution mais
qu'en même temps ce qu'on fait pour le
moment n'est pas suffisant. J'étais il y
a quelques temps avec des gens de
Alternativa et d'autres il y a 2 ou 3
ans, je sais plus à Po on a fait un
dain. Moi, je ne suis resté que 24
heures mais il y avait une rencontre
internationale de tous les gens qui font
des forages offshore tout au fond de
l'océan, des forages de plus en plus
dangereux, inutiles et tous les ans, ces
gens-là se retrouvent une fois en
Arabie, une fois à Chicago et une fois
là c'était à peau. Et on était quelques
centaines et j'étais c'est j'étais avec
les gens d'Alternative Bad à NDCOP 21,
ils ont fait un dain de façon non
violente c'està-dire comme si on était
300 ou 400 être morts pour dire au
pétrolier mais est-ce que vous
réfléchissez ? Et à chaque fois, je
trouve que ce genre d'action est utile
parce qu'il y a un dialogue. Les gens
qui font ça sont pas là pour dire "Vous
êtes nuls, vous êtes des gros nazes." À
chaque fois, c'est de façon assez
fraternelle, de façon très ferme. Ils
mettent de l'intelligence dans le
dialogue. Ils disent "Ce qui se passe
est grave, ils en appellent à la
conscience et à l'intelligence des
gens." Donc à Bruxelles l'autre jour, il
y avait en même temps, c'était super
intéressant, dimanche dernier à
Bruxelles, il y avait en même temps
Adélaï, les les mouvements d'étudiants.
Il y avait un groupe de 700 chef
d'entreprises qui disent "Maintenant, on
veut agir vraiment pour le climat." Il y
avait des élus locaux, il y avait des
ONG et puis il y avait des gens
d'extinction rébellion qui disent "Nous,
on voudrait bloquer Bruxelles, on
voudrait bloquer Londres ou Paris
pendant une semaine." Et moi, du moment
je du moment que c'est non violent,
qu'on s'en prend pas physiquement aux
personnes ou au bien, je pense que tous
les moyens de dire "On a plus que
quelques années pour agir et ça pourrait
être une opportunité." Si on prend au
sérieux la question du climat, on peut
vivre bien, créer des emplois, respirer
un air plus pur, tous les moyens non
violents, je pense pour pousser les
dirigeants à au courage. Le mur de Bern,
il est tombé. Moi, j'étais à Sciencep en
en avril 89. Le plus grand spécialiste
de l'Allemagne nous a dit que le mur de
Bernardin était encore là pendant 50
ans. On avait pas le droit de rigoler.
Par charité chrétienne, je ne donnerai
pas son nom. Mais le mec, il était ce
monsieur était sûr de lui. Voilà, ce
monsieur était sûr de lui. Et 6 mois
plus tard, le mur de Berlin est tombé.
Et si on avait attendu les grands chefs,
je pense que le mur serait encore là.
Mais ce sont des gens comme vous et moi.
Ce sont des gens qui n'ent jamais fait
de politique. Ils sont dit "Maintenant,
il y en a marre, ce système est
insupportable." Au début, ils étaient tr
ils étaient 30, ils étaient 3000 et en
quelques semaines, ils ont fait tomber
le mur de Bernardin. Donc je pense que
dans les mois qui viennent, pardon,
j'insiste, je pense que dans les mois
qui viennent, il faut qu'on se donne les
moyens de faire converger tous ces
mouvements pour qu'on oblige les
politiques à passer à l'action.
On va on va faire converger.
Ouais. Jean euh quand on voit Bolsonaro
euh euh quand on voit Bolsonaro euh
continuer de promouvoir [grognement] la
déforestation pour que le PIB de son
pays augmente et que en gros c'est de la
subordnation de vote à travers la
déforestation, c'est-à-dire il fait
rentrer des dollars de PIB et derrière
les gens revotent pour lui. comment les
les pouvoirs publics maintenant
accueillent le nouveau rapport du GC ?
Est-ce que en gros ça les ça les ennuie
de mettre en de trouver des solutions ou
de trouver des préconisations ? Parce
que derrière ces préconisations vont
être douloureuses pour la la plebe, si
je peux me permettre de de l'appeler
comme ça.
C'est-à-dire
ce sevrage énergétique, ce sevrage de de
l'ultra consommation, quand vous êtes
addicte, ça devient pénible.
Euh comment les les gouvernements vous
perçoivent face à ça ? Ils vous
perçoivent
comme des empêcheurs de tourner en rond,
comme ceux qu' on avait pas trop envie
de les les écouter mais on est un peu
obligé.
Oui, je pense que oui, c'est un peu
cette attitude de quelqu qu'ils ont
je crois que les décideurs politiques se
rendent bien compte qu'ils ne peuvent
pas ignorer le diagnostic des
scientifiques et c'est d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon qu'ils ont emmené notre
monde en bateau puisque quand on regarde
le disons si on regarde le premier
rapport du GX en 90 d en 92 et signé la
convention climat donc qui dont
l'objectif est de stabiliser enfin de
viser à stabiliser l'effet de serre.
Alors, il y a pas d'objectif chiffré
dans la convention climat au sommet de
la terre de Rio. L'objectif chiffré se
met en place à partir de Copenhag en en
2009 et puis surtout à Paris dans
l'accord de Paris en 2015. Donc d'une
certaine façon quand on regarde le
disons l'accord de Paris, l'objectif de
l'accord de Paris c'est exactement il
s'appuie complètement sur le rapport du
GC. Donc d'une certaine façon les
décideurs politiques au niveau
planétaire ont décidé de s'appuyer sur
les connaissances scientifiques.
Alors non pas pour prendre des décisions
mais pour mettre en place des textes
hein. là parce que donc quand on regarde
l'accord de Paris effectivement euh en
gros les scientifiques nous disent que
pour s'adapter au réchauffement
climatique quand même on voit bien que
au-delà de 2 degrés ce sera difficile et
puis il y a un an maintenant ils ont dit
qu'G5 ça serait disons ça serait quand
même mieux de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1 degré et demi 1 demi
degré de plus qu'aujourd'hui hein parce
qu'on a déjà pris 1 degré et bien c'est
ce qui est inscrit dans l'accord de
Paris donc on a on a le sentiment
d'avoir été écouté Mais la réalité c'est
que les engagements qui ont été pris
dans l'accord de Paris et là ce sont
bien sûr des politiques qui le prennent
sont loin du compte. En fait les
engagements pris dans l'accord de Paris
nous emmènent de façon irrésistible si
ils sont respectés. Ce qui n'est pas le
cas. Quand on regarde Bolzonaro pour
revenir à votre
disons à votre introduction de de cette
question Bolsonaro ou bien disons bien
sûr les États-Unis hein
les États-Unis Brésil sont en train de
quitter d'une certaine façon l'accord de
Paris et donc les objectifs de l'accord
de Paris qui sont minimal minimaux qui
ne remplissent pas l'obje enfin disons
qui ne répondent pas à l'objectif
scientifique à l'objectif de degré et
bien ne seront pas tenus en En fait, si
on veut tenir l'objectif de degrés, il
faut multiplier par 3 les engagements de
l'accord de Paris sur 2020 et les
multiplier par 5 pour 1 degré et demi.
Donc, on voit bien qu'on est loin du
compte. Il faudrait remonter de façon
très forte les multiplier par 3 voire
par 5 les accords de Paris sur 2020.
Si on voulait vraiment rester, disons
dans un monde où les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui pourront s'adapter. C'est
bien ça le problème, c'est pas au-delà
de 2 degrés, il y a des capacités,
disons les capacités d'adaptation et
bien commencent à à diminuer. C'est le
cas par exemple les récifs coraliens
au-delà de degrés risquent d'être
complètement perturbés.
En tout cas, il y a disons attaqué les
les récifes coraliens et donc c'est un
vrai problème pour beaucoup de régions.
On est loin du compte donc et en plus
bien sûr c'est la la neutralité carbone.
Ce que je veux dire pour la du point de
vue politique en France aussi on a une
loi qui est tout à fait ambitieuse
puisque la loi sur la transition
énergétique, la loi climat énergie
disons s'est inscrite dans cette
nécessité de neutralité carbone à
horizon 2050 % de réduction de gaz effet
de ser à horizon 2030. Donc disons dans
les textes effectivement d'une certaine
façon nos décideurs politiques s'appuent
sur les sur les sur les disons sur les
rapports sur les diagnostics des
scientifiques. Mais là où il y a un
fossé entre les textes et ce qui se
passe sous nos yeux chaque jour. Et
c'est là où le fossé est énorme et
disons se creuse d'année en année dans
certains pays.
Jean, je peux vous demander de
synthétiser ça d'une façon beaucoup plus
triviale et avec des mots beaucoup plus
fleuris. que le le pékin landa pourrait
comprendre.
Ben en gros oui, en gros les distur
politiques disons signent disons
disons effectivement nous ne tiennent
pas en gros ne font pas suffisamment
pour que ce qu'il signe se mette en
place. Mais il faut pas non plus
regarder que les les décideurs
politiques, c'est chacun d'entre nous
qui est qui nous sommes chacun d'entre
nous concernés par ces émission. Donc je
disons je vois bien la difficulté. On
peut aussi disons taper enfin disons
redire que les décideurs politiques ne
font pas ce qu'ils ne mettent pas en
place les instruments pour que ce qu'ils
ont signé, ce qu'ils ont ratifié dans le
casre de l'accord de Paris puisse être
respecté. Mais euh coupable, c'est la
population,
c'est chacun d'entre nous. Tout le monde
est tout le monde est concerné. La
population bien sûr, les entreprises
sont aussi concerné, elle doit aussi se
développer les décideurs politiques,
mais non simplement les décideurs
politiques à échelle planétaire mais les
élus. Alors, les élus européens Pierre,
c'est très important, mais les élus
locaux, la réalité du réchauffement
climatique, quand on va parler de
mobilité, quand on va parler de
d'habitat, quand voilà, c'est quand même
à l'échelle disons des régions, des
communes, des communautés de communes
que ça se passe aussi la production
d'énergie. Donc c'est c'est là vraiment
aussi à tous les niveaux les les
décideurs politiques sont concernés mais
tout le monde est concerné et nous-même
chacun d'entre nous. pire
mais surtout que ça bouge pas on a l'
tous les maires ruraux de France
l'association des maires ruraux et des
petites villes qui étaient avec nous
pour obtenir ce ce pacte climat au
niveau européen. Moi je pense quand même
que votre question était vraiment juste
et beaucoup de politiques pensent que ça
va être douloureux pour la pleb voilà
que le voilà et donc les deux mots sont
importants. La plebe parce qu'on au lieu
de penser que chaque citoyen a un
cerveau est capable de réfléchir et
d'agir on pense que c'est la plebe et on
pense que ça va a priori être
douloureux. Or, nous ce qu'on pense
c'est que ça peut être une bonne
nouvelle que si on prend au sérieux la
question du climat, si on se donne on
sait ce qu'il faut faire pour sauver le
climat, on sait hein, il faut isoler
tous les bâtiments publics et privés. Il
faut développer des transports en commun
pour que le minimum de gens aient besoin
de leur voiture. La plupart des gens, il
faut qu'ils puissent prendre soit le
vélo, soit marcher à pied, soit des
transports en commun. Il faut
transformer le modèle agricole et tout
ça et ça peut créer des emplois et ça
peut être une bonne nouvelle. J'étais
l'autre jour, je sais pas si vous avez
vu le film demain, un des exemples que
donne Cyril Dion, c'est la ferme de
Charles Perine au bec et loin. C'est
juste génial quand vous allez chez
Charles Périne, vous avez envie de de
rester avec eux tellement il y a un
sentiment d'équilibre, ils arrivent à
produire des fruits, des légumes avec
zéro pesticides, zéro pétrole et
l'argent qu'ils économisent sur le
pétrole et les pesticides, ils l'ont
transformé en masse salariale. Et là où
une ferme aurait pu fonctionner avec
juste un adulte ou deux adultes, ils
sont 7 ou h et on voit bien que les gens
sont heureux. Donc ça crée de l'emploi.
Les gens qui mangent ces produits, c'est
meilleur pour leur santé et c'est
meilleur pour la planète. Et c'est
équilibré. C'est du point de vue
économique. Simplement, il faudrait que
l'ensemble des agriculteurs qu'on les
aide qu' les la plupart des agriculteurs
ont le couteau sous la gorge. La plupart
des paysans n'arrivent même pas à se
payer un SMIC, ils ont surendetté. Donc
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce que les
politiques peuvent aider à une
réinfection dans l'agriculture et dire
pendant 2 ou 3 ans, votre champ va être
moins rentable, on vous donne une aide
financière sur l'isolation. Je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure. L'autre jour, j'étais à
Grenoble. Un monsieur qui vit dans HLM
depuis 15 ans disait "J'ai gagné 800 €
par an sur mes dépenses de chauffage."
La question savoir comment est-ce qu'on
finance un plan d'investissement très
massif ? Et là, la question de la
justice fiscale que demandent les gilets
jaunes, elle est cruciale quand on sait
que 30 % des Français n'ont pas 1 €
d'économie, que 30 % des Européens sont
dans le rouge tous les mois, il y en a
qui se sont engueulés tous les mois par
leurs banquiers. La question de qui paye
pour faire ce ce plan d'investissement
est très importante. Celui qui prend sa
voiture tous les jours pour aller au
boulot, est-ce qu'on va lui demander de
payer plus de taxes ou est-ce qu'on
trouve d'autres financements ? Et ce
qu'on dit,
ben la cour des comptes européennes, la
cour des comptes dit que si on veut
vraiment dans tous les pays d'Europe
isoler les bâtiments, développer les
transports en commun, aider
l'agriculture à se transformer,
développer les renouvelables, la Cour
des comptes dit qu'il faut chaque année
1100 milliards d'euros. Je vous
c'est à peu près ce que le système
bancaire se fait injecter par les
banques central.
Il a lu notre bouquin enfin il
connaissait le sujet avant. Non mais
juste c'est très intéressant parce que
la cour des comptes en général c'est des
trucs qu'on lit le soir qu'on a du mal à
dormir faut être honnête. Et là ils se
sont lâchés. La cour des comptes
européennes s'est lâché en disant qu'il
y en a marre des scénarios où tout finit
bien en 2050 parce que maintenant tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut la neutralité en 2050. Et la Cour
des comptes dit que ça n'est pas sérieux
parce qu'en fait la Commission
européenne compte sur une succession de
miracles juste à la fin que tout d'un
coup en 2040 on va trouver le budget,
que tout d'un coup en 2043 il y aura le
saut technologique et que dans des pays
laïques, on peut pas compter sur Saint
Rita et la la patronne des causes
désespérées, une accumulation du miracle
à la fin. Donc la Cour des comptes dit à
la Commission européenne, vous n'êtes
pas sérieux. Vous n'êtes pas sérieux.
C'est pas en 2040 que ça va se jouer,
c'est dès l'année prochaine, il faut
trouver chaque année 1100 milliards
d'euros. Et si on veut trouver 1100
milliards, nous ce qu'on dit avec gens
et avec d'autres, c'est qu'il faut
obliger les banques et les assurances à
stopper pour de vrai les investissement
fossile et à mettre tous leurs sous en 4
ou 5 ans vers ce qui est bon pour la
planète.
Raconte-moi ça. Comment on fait pour
forcer les banques à faire quelque chose
? Je te rappelle je te rappelle je te
rappelle que la dernière fois qu'on a
essayé de leur forcer à séparer les
banques d'affaires et les banques de
détail, ils nous ont regardé, ils ont
bien rigolé, ils ont pris beaucoup de
pognons pour sauver les banques, du
pognon public. Et là donc on fait
comment pour l'instant
mais la question est-ce qu'on a une
volonté politique quand Roosevelt
oui pardon c'est un mot grossier pardon
mais moi [grognement] si si on est là
c'est qu'on pense qu'on peut faire
bouger les choses
mais merci Jean je suis heureux de ton
soutien non [rires] mais on pense que ça
attendez je suis tout à fait sérieux ça
ne se fera pas spontanément voilà si on
est là aujourd'hui on est content c'est
qu'on pense qu'il y a besoin je suis
député européen depuis 3 mois je l'avais
pas vu venir mais j'en suis très heureux
mais même député je pense que s'il n'y a
pas une pression des citoyens ça ne va
pas bouger tout est fait pour que les
gens aille voter une fois tous les 5 ans
et qu'il se rendorment tranquillou
pendant 4 ans et demi. Et je pense que
le rôle du citoyen, c'est pas seulement
de voter une fois tous les 5 ans et
d'aller dormir, c'est d'être vraiment
très exigeant et de une pression
fraternelle mais très forte sur les les
dirigeants. Là, la campagne qui a été
lancée l'autre jour en en Belgique,
c'est nos garanties, nos votes. ceux qui
étaient devant le parlement, il disait,
on vous demande les députés de dire vous
ne pourrez pas voter pour Ursula Vander
Layon, vous ne pourrez pas voter pour la
nouvelle commission le 23 octobre si on
n pas des garanties chiffrées sur le
financement. Donc la volonté politique
c'est Roosevelt qui fait la séparation
des banques en 3 mois. Les banquiers
gueulent en dis doncant que c'est un
communiste qui va tuer l'Amérique mais
Roosevelt a fait la séparation des
banques et ça tenue pendant 60 ans. On a
eu ça s'appelle le Glastigle Act et
c'est des libéraux qui ont réussi à le
en l'air et depuis on va de crise
en crise quand et de un autre exemple
plus récent c'est quand Barack Obama
fait la loi Fatka c'était pas il y a 3
siècles he Barack Obama on a connu
récemment et pour permettre pour lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale Barack Obama
fait une loi qui dit que aucune banque
ne pourra travailler sur le territoire
américain. Ça n'est pas totalement
transparente sur toutes les activités
mondiales pour le fisque américain. Et
là, c'est pareil. Les banques disent que
c'est un communiste et qui va tuer le le
business. Et Barack Obama tient bon
pendant 8 mois et la loi Fatka est
passée et toutes les banques sont
transparentes. Donc ce qu'on demande
c'est qu'au niveau européen, puisque
madame Vayon dit que c'est sa priorité
le climat, on dit super bravo, votre
discours était formidable et maintenant
on passe au concret. Il faut une loi
Fatka Climat qui dit que plus aucune
banque ou aucune assurance ne peut
travailler en Europe dans les 5 ans qui
viennent. Ce n'est pas transparente
totalement sur toutes ces activités.
Deuxièmement, on stoppe les nouveaux
investissements bruns et troisièmement,
en 4 ou 5 ans, on se désengage. L'autre
priorité qu'on pousse avec gens, c'est
dire jamais il y a eu autant d'argent.
Il y a un an, on a fait une réunion à
l'Élysée à Matignon, je donnerai pas de
nom, mais quelqu'un nous a arraché des
mains. Donc la Cour des comptes dit
qu'il faut 1000 milliards chaque année.
Et c'est un de nos slogans avec Michel
Rocard, on a expliqué ou avec Stéphane
Essel, feu Michel Rocard ou feu Stéphane
Essel, mais on essaie de reprendre le
flambeau.
Notre slogan c'était en 2008. Quand il y
a eu la crise financière, on a mis 1000
milliards pour sauver les banques et on
devrait faire pareil pour sauver le
climat. Mais certains rigolaient en
disant "Mais vous n'êtes pas sérieux, la
Banque centrale européenne a fait ça une
fois parce que c'était sinon
l'effondrement financier et jamais la
banque centrale ne voudra recommencer."
Et puis tout de suite que tu es pas
sérieux tout de suite he que je sois pas
sérieux.
La Banque centrale européenne, elle est
remplie gavée de de de d'obligations
mais qui ne tiennent pas la route. Elle
est en train de se poser des questions
sur sa propre stabilité. Donc là, tu es
en train de lui demander 1000 milliards.
Non, pardon, je suis pas en train de lui
demander. Je dis juste et la plupart des
citoyens ne le savent pas et même le
ministre de l'économie Wallon disait
qu'il ne savait pas et il y a un an, on
a fait une réunion à l'Élysée et à
Matignon dans le casadre du lobbying en
France et quelqu'un de très haut placé à
Matignon me l'a arraché des mains. Donc
c'est juste que fin 2014 la banque
centrale, je ne vous parle pas de 2008
situation d'urgence, je vous dis juste
que fin 2014 et là c'est comme ça. Tu
as pas dans ton micro
pardon fin 2014 la banque centrale
annonce qu'elle va créer 1000 milliards.
Quand j'étais petit, on appelait ça la
planche habillée. Maintenant, on met des
mots techniques pour que la plupart des
citoyens se disent "Je n'y comprends
rien, je vais dire des bêtises, vaut
mieux pas que je me mêle." Mais c'est
bien ça. Et au total, la BCE a créé 2600
milliards d'euros à peu près en 3 ans.
2600 milliards d'euros en 3 ans. Donc 90
% est parti à la spéculation. Donc nous
ce qu'on dit avec gens et d'autres c'est
est-ce qu'on continue à donner toujours
plus d'argent pour les banques et la
spéculation ou est-ce que cet argent
pourrait aller pour financer les
transports en commun pour financer
l'isolation de nos maisons et de de nos
écoles ? Bon là, on a on a on a notre
politicien qui parle, il est il est
regaillardi, il est courageux, il est
plein d'espoir. [soupir][souffle coupé]
Bon là, on va parler un peu entre
scientifiques.
Euh euh
vous avez pas l'impression qu'il
brassent tous un peu du vent et qu'il
sculpte un peu de l'air chaud pour euh
pour pour faire un parallèle avec le
réchauffement climatique ? C'est parce
que c'est très beau, c'est très beau. On
va on va trouver des solutions, on va
faire pipi dans la douche, on va se
laver les dents, on va fermer le
robinet. Mais toute cette industrie qui
a mis 50 ans à émerger, toutes ces
barrières psychologiques, toutes ces
adhérences de consommation, tous ces
modèles de croissance qu'on a on a
bétonné dans la tête des gamins, on a
bétonné dans la génération des
trentenaires, des quarantairs,
c'est c'est cette inertie sociétale,
cette immaturité quand le scientifique
voit ça, quand il se balade dans la rue
qu'il voit des zombies, quel Bah Donc
oui alors oui, j'ai quand même parlé de
je me veux provoque.
Non mais c'est très bien. Alors est-ce
que le citoyen peut effectivement
contribuer par sa réflexion, par ses
propositions à effectivement disons
clairement changer le mode de
développement parce que c'est bien de ça
dont on parle quand même. On peut parler
d'efficacité énergétique, c'est faire
les mêmes choses avec moins d'énergie,
c'est très bien. Mais il faut aussi
parler de sobriété, c'est très clair. on
n'y arrivera pas. Et alors la question
est posée puisque disons à partir de la
semaine prochaine vont se réunir donc la
va se réunir la convention citoyenne
pour le climat. Donc c'est organisé par
le conseil économique, social et
environnemental.
Donc je suis membre du conseil de
gouvernance donc on travaille depuis 2
mois sur la préparation de cette
convention citoyenne. Thierry Pêche,
Laurence Tubana sont disons président de
ce comité de gouvernance. Voilà, ça va
commencer dans une semaine maintenant.
Et euh effectivement les les c'est c'est
je crois un test grandeur nature pour
voir si on va ça va se dérouler pendant
quelques mois [grognement] euh 4 à 5
mois et puis disons les propositions qui
seront faites. La question qui est posée
à ces citoyens c'est une France
miniature tirage au sort. Les 150
citoyens seront là que
il y a que mett dit dedans. Le hasard
oui le hasard. Alors, il non que Con
[grognement] Bendit a été effectivement
appelé mais il a refusé semble-t-il euh
mais c'est vrai que le tirage au sort a
bien fait les choses puisque Daniel
Comendit, on nous a dit qu'il avait été
appelé effectivement mais qu'il a refusé
de d'être dans ce panel de citoyens.
Donc ça aurait été effectivement bien
peut-être que qu'il soit là mais voilà
les 15 citoyens seront là et ont
effectivement ça va être organisé autour
de bah des grands thèmes se loger, se
nourrir se déplacer.
Ils ont produire, consommer puis aussi
une réflexion transversale sur la taxe
carbone, sur la fiscalité
environnementale et parce que justement
c'est important ce que ce qui est
demandé à ces citoyens, c'est quelle
mesure qu'est-ce que vous quelle
proposition feriez-vous
pour nous mettre en avant pour qu'en
France pour que la France respecte ses
engagements à Horizon 2030 ? C'est une
question très simple. En fait, on a déjà
du retard et on voit bien que c'est pas
simple de diminuer. Alors, ça fait
pratiquement 25 % par rapport
aujourd'hui sur 10 ans. Et ce qui ce à
quoi
disons Édouard Philippe s'est engagé
dans sa lettre de mission et je crois
que le président de la République
viendra le redire à ses citoyens et bien
c'est disons que toutes les propositions
que vous faites seront regardées
appelleront des réponses soit au niveau
du législatif soit au niveau de
l'exécutif soit au niveau du
réglementaire mais donc voilà un petit
peu et bon j'espère que que des choses
vont se passer par rapport au cycl C'est
complémentaire d'autres approches. Ces
rapproches citoyens n'empêchent pas
celles disons sont plutôt
complémentaires de celle que fait Pierre
ou essaie essaie de mener au niveau
européen. Je pense qu'il y a une
évolution chez les citoyens qui est très
intéressante, impressionnante. Il y a un
an, j'ai été invité par l'événement de
rent pour l'événement de rentrée des
jeunes agriculteurs, le syndicat des
jeunes agriculteurs et le jeune paysan
qui était là disait "Ce débat était
inimaginable il y a 10 ans. Il y a 10
ans, Claude Allègre était notre héros et
les écolos nous cassaient les pieds pour
être poli." Et il disait "Aujourd'hui,
il n'y a plus aucun paysan qui est
climatosceptique. Il y a 2 ans, les il y
a 3 ans, les inondations en scène ont
fait qu'on a perdu 30 % de la récolte de
blé. Cette année, il y a tellement de
sécheresses qu'on a' pas on a'ura pas
assez de foin et on va devoir abattre
une partie des troupeaux. Donc il
disait, c'était un des responsables
nationales des jeunes agriculteurs,
disit en 10 ans ça a tout changé dans
nos têtes. Maintenant le problème est
financièrement comment est-ce qu'on fait
? Je sais lui il était éleveur. Il sait
il dit au lieu de mettre le lisier que
ça va abîmer la napatique et ça va
abîmer l'atmosphère, je sais qu'on
pourrait faire du biogaz que maintenant
c'est au point. Le problème c'est que
c'est 500000 € pour faire une unité de
biogaz. La plupart des paysans
n'arrivent pas à se payer le SMIC tous
les mois. Donc si on demande à chaque
paysan de trouver 500000 € c'est pas
possible. Il disait par contre s'il y a
un pacte européen qui paye la moitié de
la facture et on est sûr que pendant 30
ans on va nous acheter le biogaz et ben
là c'est possible. On se met à deux ou
trois fermes ensemble, on va créer un
emploi ou deux emplois et c'est
possible. Don de même la plupart des
gens c'est pas pour le plaisir qu'ils
prennent leur voiture mais moi je suis
dans le coin des Pyrénées où ceux qui
ont du boulot à Argelais soit lourde ils
sont obligés. Il y a pas de transport en
commun. Il y a un bus le matin et un bus
le soir. Donc ou bien on développe des
transports en commun, ou bien on
développe des systèmes de travail à
distance si on avait internet au débit
partout. Mais en tout cas, moi je pense
énergie internet pardon.
Très énergivor internet.
Oui, mais on peut faire des économies
par ailleurs si on fait des économies
sur l'efficacité énergétique et puis
j'en l'a dit, il y a besoin de sobriété.
Là, j'ai mis une chemise frugalité
frugalité. Là, je hier j'avais une
chemise complètement râpée et si on voit
la poubelle des vêtements dès qu'ils
sont un peu usés, on s'en sortira pas.
Là, comme je suis filmé, j'ai mis une ch
Non mais sans rire, je pense que chacun
de nous doit se dire même si mon
téléphone est vieux, je peux garder un
vieux téléphone. Même si ma chemise ou
ma robe est un peu usée, je peux garder
le On peut vivre très heureux en ayant
des chemises un tout petit peu élimées.
On peut vivre très heureux dans une
maison qui est isolée. On peut vivre
très heureux en ne mangeant pas de la
viande tous les jours. J'ai été levé au
jambon de Bayonne comme tous les basques
cubernés du pays, mais j'arrive à manger
moins de viande et je vis très heureux.
Plutôt polygamie ou plutôt polyandrie
pour le réchauffement climatique ?
Ce qui veut dire plus précisément folie.
Polygamie ou polyondrie pour le
réchauffement climatique, il faut
choisir quoi ?
J'ai pas compris la question. J'ai entué
le cerveau
polygamie. Non non.
Alors la l'inverse de la polygamie,
c'est la polyandrie.
Oui.
D'accord.
Donc il faut reconsidérer la la
structure familiale, il faut bannir le
divorce. Il faut faire quoi ?
Oh je pense qu'on peut garder un grand
niveau un haut niveau de liberté. Tous
ceux qui vous disent qu'il faut une
dictature pour sauver la planète n'ont
rien compris.
Alors, on va on va y venir parce que
c'est une question qui fait venir mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on lise un message de
Marie-Claude.
Ah voilà, c'était une question
qui qui est à l'instant alors son
message à l'instant même nous marchons
pour le climat à Montréal. Greta Tonberg
et David Suzuki nous accompagnent. Le
Canada est en pleine campagne
électorale. Aucun des candidats n'offre
des propositions claires et vigoureuses
pour ne serait-ce qu'envisager de
freiner l'effondrement des écosystèmes,
l'érosion, la biodiversité. Et
croyez-vous que de ne pas voter ne
serait pas plus efficace pour manifester
et l'urgence d'agir de notre profonde
colère vis-à-vis de leur inertie ? C'est
pas des mesures un peu de petits bras ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas passer à un
système un peu plus totalitaire ?
C'est-à-dire une bonne dictature, on
fait crever tous les pauvres, on impose
des mesures sur le l'évasion fiscale à
la hache et on arrête de rigoler.
Oui, mais c'est ce qui va se passer
malheureusement. Non, mais pas les gens,
je veux lire par le le vrai risque de
réchauffement climatique, c'est quand
même l'accroissement des inégalités, je
l'ai déjà dit, mais c'est en gros c'est
quoi le réchauffement climatique ? C'est
aussi disons diminuer la surface où il
fait bon vivre. Donc et je crains et on
peut craindre vraiment que les riches
sachent toujours trouver les endroits où
il fait bon vivre et laissent disons les
les les pauvres et bien s'angluer dans
les endroits où il y a des difficultés
par rapport au réchauffement climatique.
C'est ça qui il faut prendre de la
mesure de cela. dès maintenant et donc
il faut vraiment aller de l'avant et bon
ce qui ce qui est pour pour le Canada
même si Justine Trudeau est quand même
plus disons plus sérieux par rapport à
la lutte contre l'échauffement
climatique que n'était Harpeur avant qui
était vraiment complètement
climatoceptique, ce progrès n'est pas
suffisant parce qu'en Alberta on explo
enfin on explore toujours on exploite
toujours de plus en plus de gaz de
chiste. Donc ce n'est même pas justement
c'est ça qui m'attriste un peu, c'est
qu'un disons un chef d'état comme Justin
Trudeau qui visiblement a envie de faire
des choses n'y arrive pas et c'est pour
cela bon je j'espère que cette marche de
Montréal aura quand même un disons un
impact dans ce pays et aussi bien
au-delà parce que c'est ça qu'il faut
c'est entraîner des pays comme le Canada
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique. C'est clair. Pierre,
faudra des mesures contraignantes. Euh,
évidemment, c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas,
il y aura il faut euh on peut pas, il
faudra dire que dans 20 ans, tous les
bâtiments doivent être isolés, que dans
15 ans, plus aucune voiture ne peut
rouler si elle émit du CO2. Il faudra
dire que effectivement, il faut isoler
les bâtiments. Il faut qu'on ch quand
qu'on arrête l'avion. L'avion, on doit
prendre, ça doit être exceptionnel de
prendre l'avion. Il y a des TGV partout.
On peut beaucoup moins circuler, on peut
passer des vacances [raclement de gorge]
très agréables en France ou à proximité.
Je pense qu'il faut nous c'est pour ça
qu'on d'abord quand vous dites que c'est
des mesures des demi-mesures, le projet
comporte quand même, il y aurait 400
milliards chaque année en Europe entre
ce qu'on propose sur la banque du climat
et le budget, il y aurait chaque année
400 milliards sur la table en Europe.
Donc ça peut créer 5 millions en emploi
et ça changerait tout plus un plan
marchal pour l'Afrique. Et on propose
que ce pacte soit approuvé par un
référendum le même jour dans tous les
pays d'Europe. C'est l'idée de Abermas,
le grand philosophe allemand qui dit que
l'Europe va crever si elle a pas un
nouveau projet et que l'Europe va crever
si elle a peur des citoyens. Et donc
Abermas dit le prochain traité pourrait
être approuvé le même jour ou la même
semaine par un référendum dans tous les
pays d'Europe. On aura un débat
passionnant sur le climat, la
biodiversité, sur la création monétaire.
On verrait qu'en fait tout le monde peut
comprendre les questions monétaires. On
a tout fait pour que les citoyens n'y
comprennent rien et on aurait un débat
passionnant. Et les gens qui voteraient
oui pour le pacte climat devraient dire
aussi est-ce que moi dans mon
comportement je peux changer ma ma façon
de vivre au quotidien et je pense qu'on
créerait une dynamique très forte. Donc
ça n'est pas une dictature mais c'est
décidé ensemble. Un référendum, c'est au
contraire un sursaut démocratique. C'est
décidé ensemble qu'on va taxer le
kérosène, que c'est pas normal que
quelqu'un qui prend sa voiture pour
aller au boulot paye des taxes tous les
tous les jours quand il fait son plein
et que quelqu'un qui prend l'avion pour
le fun une fois par mois ne paye pas de
taxe. Donc je pense qu'on peut décider
ensemble de nouveaux modes de vie et que
c'est il y a aucune opposition entre
dans mes dans mon enfance enfin mes
parents adoraient Pierre Mandz France.
Le siècle dernier.
Voilà le siècle dernier. Merci sympa
Bertrand. Euh tu balances donc c'est une
réalité
et France a expliqué que le manque de
justice sociale vient d'un manque de
démocratie que si on était dans un
système vraiment démocratique, il n'y
aurait pas autant de pauvreté et
d'inégalité et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
que le manque d'action sur le climat
vient d' une insuffisance démocratique.
J'étais l'autre jour avec Bruno Lemire
il y a quelques jours, il nous avait
reçu à quelques députés. Il nous
expliquait que le climat c'était sa
priorité, la priorité. Et je lui ai dit,
excusez-moi, mais je suis le rapporteur
au niveau européen pour le prochain
budget européen et le budget du climat
va reculer de moins 1,3 %. Reculer de
1,3 % le prochain budget climat. Je dis
ça n'est pas une priorité. Gros silence
de Bruno Lemire. Et je lui dis et c'est
d'autant moins compréhensible que la
banque centrale va recommencer sa
planche habillée et qu'on va avoir 240
milliards dans l'année qui vient. La
banque centrale vient d'annoncer qu'elle
va mettre 240 milliards sur la table
qu'elle va donner aux banques en
espérant que les banques vont agir pour
le bien commun. Et donc je demandé à
notre ministre comment est-ce qu'on peut
justifier que le budget climat va
reculer de 1,3 % alors que la BCE va
créer 240 milliards et sa réponse c'est
Pierre ma porte est toujours ouverte on
se voit quand vous voulez. Donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on mette des arguments sur
la table. Je pense vraiment que il y a
des gens qui se découragent. ce n'est
pas le moment de se décourager. Je pense
qu'au contraire grâce hélas la gravité
de la situation est telle et puis les
mouvements des étudiants, le travail des
climatologues, moi je pense qu'on est au
contraire dans le moment où on peut
faire basculer. On est un moment de
vérité au niveau européen et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que les citoyens poussent
les députés, poussent les politiques au
courage.
Euh euh bon, ça fait plus de 40 40
années que vous êtes dans la
climatologie. [souffle coupé]
On parle de solastalgie de dépression
chez les scientifiques. Vous vous l'avez
senti un peu ? Comment ça va votre
dépression ?
Non, ce qui se passe c'est les
scientifiques
disons on a été long enfin bon peut-être
pas moi, mais disons beaucoup des des
scientifiques par bon moi c'est per
Simon la place qui regroupe sur la
région parisienne l'ensemble des des
laboratoires impliqués. En fait euh de
depuis depuis quelques mois, il y a une
réelle prise de conscience et les
scientifiques veulent effectivement voir
ce qu'ils peuvent faire vis-à-vis du
grand public. Il y a peut-être plus de
désir qu'il n'y avait il y a quelques
années d'aller vers le public, vers les
décideurs politiques pour effectivement
avancer. Il y a il y a aussi une des
vraies initiatives dans les
laboratoires. Il y a une réflexion qui
se met en place qui disons par rapport à
à notre positionnement de scientifique.
C'est-à-dire cette idée qu'il ne suffit
pas de de simplement
disons faire la science, même la la
dire, mais il faut aussi faire partie
être nous-même dans l'action. Et donc il
y a il y a beaucoup de de scientifiques
qui qui ont maintenant cette position.
Je crois que c'est quand même assez
intéressant. On doit sortir de notre
Cour d'Ivoire. Donc maintenant, par
rapport à la question, je pense qu'il
faut, moi je suis bien sûr je suis très
attaché à la démocratie. On voit bien
que disons on peut penser que des
régimes totri ou semi-totalitaires
pourraient être plus efficaces, mais je
crois qu'il faut aussi aller de l'avant
avec la démocratie. C'est possible. Et
donnons l'exemple en Europe. Justement,
ce que je souhaite, c'est que l'Europe
réussisse simplement à respecter les
objectifs qu'elle s'est fixé. En fait,
neutralité carbone, c'est en France. Il
y a 24 pays européens qui l'ont adopté
l'idée de la neutralité carbone.
J'espère qu'une des décisions sera quand
même que d'entraîner l'Europe vers la
neutralité carbone de Horizon 2050.
Faisons-le. Alors, on peut toujours dire
c'est pas suffisant. L'Europe, c'est 10
% des émissions, c'est vrai ou un peu
moins, mais c'est synonyme de dynamisme
économique de réussir cette transition.
Et je suis de ceux qui pensent que ce
dynamisme économique finalement
irriguera l'ensemble de la planète.
Sérieusement dans 10 ans ce
réchauffement climatique si on a encore
pris de diè de degrés de ou 3 diè de
degrés 2/è certainement et bien les gens
commenceront sérieusement à réaliser que
nous avons raison et commenceront et il
y aura vraiment une montée non pas enfin
disons une montée du de je crois de
beaucoup de de plus en plus de monde
pour dire ce n'est pas possible ce n'est
pas possible d'aller vers 4 à 5°gr à la
fin du siècle si nous sommes encore sur
cette trajectoire si nous nous
mais mais c'est bien cela mais un moment
Déjà, c'est ce que disent les jeunes,
mais ça va, je je pense que le
réchauffement climatique va se
poursuivre et que ce le mouvement de
fond disons de de chacun d'entre nous,
les citoyens va prendre de plus en plus
de place. C'est pas acceptable
cette idée. Bien sûr, dans la colère qu'
a exprimé Greta Louanu, je pense qu'on
sera des millions à avoir de la haine en
disant "Mais purée, vous n'avez rien
fait, vous le saviez." Ce que je dis à
mes collègues députés, c'est qu'on aura
honte de nous. On se fera engueuler par
nos enfants mais chacun de nous aura
honte en disant je savais nous aurions
pu agir et je répète ça pourrait être
une opportunité sur mais il faut juste
avoir le courage de mettre la finance au
service du bien communes n'ont jamais
été aussi je vous ai montré l'argent de
la banque centrale mais j'ai encore deux
graphiques à vous montrer. C'est montré
comment il y a jamais eu autant de
dividendes. Vous voyez ça c'est le
courbe c'est les bénéfices non
réinvestis. C'est les dividendes. Voilà.
Et dans le même temps, on baisse l'impôt
sur les bénéfices. De moi quand j'étais
petit, l'impôt sur les bénéfices était à
45 % et maintenant on est tombé à 19 %
en Europe. Depuis que l'Angleterre est
rentrée, c'est à qui va baisser le plus
l'impôt sur les bénéfices. Alors que aux
États-Unis, de Roosevelt jusqu'à Trump,
l'impôt sur les bénéfices c'était à 38
%. Donc c'est on nous dit qu'on a'a pas
d'argent pour financer la transition
écologique mais il y a jamais eu autant
de bénéfices et jamais eu autant de
dividendes. Le Figaro, le le journal de
l'Ultra gauche a mis l'autre jour les
dividendes augmentent de + 23 % en 1 an.
+ 23 % et à cause de notre bêtise, c'est
pas le reste du monde, c'est juste la
concurrence qu'on s'impose entre pays
européens. On a divisé par deux l'impôt
sur les bénéfices. Donc juste nous on
propose deux choses très simples. Dire
l'argent de la banque centrale au lieu
d'aller à la spéculation, il pourrait
aller dans une banque du climat pour
financer, que tous on soit aidé pour
isoler nos maisons, pour faire des
transports en commun. Et puis on va
demander un petit effort aux
actionnaires. Quand les dividendes
explosent, on ne touche pas les
artisans, on ne touche pas les PME, mais
les autres on va faire un impôt européen
sur les bénéfices qui va cracher 100
milliards et on aura tous des
subventions et les Indiens et les
Chinois qui se qui font de l'électricité
avec du charbon. Et bien on peut mettre
en même temps une taxe carbone aux
frontières dans et puis en même temps je
pense que ce qu'a dit est très
important. Il peut avoir un effet de
contagion parce que si on attend que
ta tout ça
mais on peut tout mettre sur la table.
Je pense effectivement que c'est en
train de bouger même Emmanuel Macron qui
explique qu'il faut revoir l'accord sur
le avec le Mercosour parce que
effectivement on voit que si on et que
nous sommes coresponsables. C'est aussi
quand moi je je répète comme bon berner
j'aime bien le jambon de Bayonne mais
les cochons nourris en France viennent
c'est souvent avec des des protéines qui
viennent de de la déforestation du
Brésil. Donc évidemment Bolsonaro, il y
a pas de mot poli pour dire ce que je
peux penser de ce monsieur, mais c'est
nous aussi qui sommes responsables que
les il y a des bateaux qui traversent
l'Atlantique pour venir nourrir nos
cochons et nos nos vaches. Donc est-ce
qu'on est capable nous aussi de se dire
je ne suis pas obligé de manger de la
viande ou du poisson tous les jours. Je
peux être en pleine forme en mangeant
moins de viande. On peut avoir des
protéines sur le territoire européen et
ne pas les importer. On peut avoir un
fond qui aide à la reforestation. Je
répète, l'Europe est la première
puissance économique et financière
mondiale. On pourrait se dire qu'on
change nos modes de vie, qu'on met de
l'argent pour financer la transition en
Europe, qu'on a un vrai plan marchal
pour l'Afrique et je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un effet domino. Je suis persuadé
que si l'Europe se donne les moyens de
gagner la bataille du climat, le Japon
pourra faire pareil peut-être un an plus
tard. Au Japon aussi, il y a des
catastrophes climatiques monstrueuses.
Tous les mois, il y a des catastrophes
qui font qui font des des morts et qui
sont à la une de l'actualité. Et le
Japon a aussi une banque centrale qui
fait beaucoup trop d'argent, qui va à la
spéculation. Donc je suis persuadé que
ne serait-ce que si 12 12 ou 13 pays
d'Europe, je répète, on n' pas besoin de
l'unanimité pour avancer. Si quelques
pays d'Europe décident de prendre le
taureau par les cornes, on peut avoir un
effet de contagion et puis dans quelques
années, celui ou celle qui va remplacer
Trump se dira "On était bien couillon de
ne pas faire pareil. Nous aux
États-Unis, on est tombé en récession et
le eux, l'Europe, ils vivent bien et ils
créent des emplois."
D'accord. Créer des emplois pour
consommer. Donc créer des emplois pour
isoler je pardon ayons un débat serein
la consommation n'est pas la solution
est-ce que j'ai pas l'air serein est-ce
que j'ai l'air serein
non non pardon créer des emplois n'est
pas forcément une mauvaise chose ici on
est cin dans la pièce on a tous un
boulot correct on est h il a Pierre Paul
Jack d'accord on va arrêter de donner
des infoscord d'accord
2è édition
ok donc ce je ce que je veux dire c'est
que créer des emplois dans des un pays
où il y a quand même plus de 5 millions
de chômeurs n'est pas une mauvaise chose
créer des emplois autant je ne crois pas
au fait qu'il faille compter sur la
croissance pour sortir de de la crise ça
fait 20 ans que on écrit que la
croissance n'est pas la solution que ça
devient une partie du problème. Mais par
contre effectivement si on veut isoler
toutes les maisons, si on veut isoler
tous les bâtiments publics, si on veut
développer des transports en commun, et
bien je pense qu'il faut on va créer des
emplois et c'est plutôt une bonne chose.
C'est c'est c'est pour refaire la même
chose.
Mais non, pardon, c'est pour changer
radicalement. Pardon, c'est division
Jean l'a souligné. C'estd que le
changement de paradigme, vous l'impulsez
comment ? Parce que là à vous écouter,
bon gens un peu moins mais à t'écouter
c'est faire la même chose. C'est
pas du tout. Pardon. On va isoler, on va
créer de l'emploi, on va avoir notre
croissance.
Mais quand j'explique, il faut aussi de
la sobriété, quand j'explique qu'il faut
changer mon mon mode d'alimentation,
quand il faut changer de mode
agriculture, c'est tout qu'il faut
revoir. Je dois manger moins de viande
et la viande doit être produite
autrement. Fait l'avocat du diabè.
En quelques décennies, on a divisé par
trois la consommation de vin, mais on
fait du vin de meilleure qualité et les
gens vivent quand même correctement de
leur travail. Est-ce qu'on est capable
Est-ce qu'on est capable de transformer
d'effectivement de choisir un modèle de
sobriété où on consomme moins, on n'est
pas poussé qu'on on met fin
l'obsolescence programmée, qu'on
consomme beaucoup moins et que ce que ce
qu'on consomme est produit autrement. On
aura quand même besoin d'énergie. Toi et
moi, on a besoin de se déplacer mais
est-ce que a priori on se déplace à vélo
ou à pied ou en transport en commun ? Et
que les fois où quand même tous parfois
on aura besoin d'une voiture, est-ce que
l'Europe a inventé une voiture qui
consomme beaucoup moins et qui consomme
des renouvelables ? On a mis des
milliards pour faire Airbus et c'est un
succès. On a mis des milliards pour
faire Arian. Est-ce qu'on est capable
d'inventer un ordinateur ? Tu as devant
les yeux un ordinateur. Est-ce qu'on est
capable d'inventer un ordinateur qui va
consommer moins ou une voiture qui va
consommer moins ?
D'accord. Connaî le principe de de
l'effet rebond. C'estd qu'on fait des
trucs qui consomment moins, tout le
monde l'achète et comme ça tout le monde
consomme plus. pas forcément parce qu'en
même temps tu augmentes le prix du
carbone. Autant si ton seul levier c'est
d'augmenter le prix de l'essence, tu
auras des millions de gilets jaunes. Si
aujourd'hui la seule solution c'est la
taxe carbone, tous ceux qui n'ont pas 1
€ d'économie, tous ceux qui sont dans le
rouge mais qui ont besoin de leur
voiture vont gueuler et on les comprend.
Par contre, si tu commences par faire de
l'efficacité, si tu commences par isoler
les maisons, mettre en place des
transports en commun, tu et que tout le
monde a compris que le problème du
climat est sérieux et que c'est pas la
la lubie de quelque
prix du carbone régulièrement.
Une question pour Jean Juselle euh
est-ce que c'est vrai ? que l'ensemble
du système solaire se réchauffe.
Bon, alors là, j'ai pas non pas vrai.
Enfin, il y a il y a pas de preuve que
l'ensemble du système solaire se
réchauffe. Non, le disons en tout cas le
soleil il y a pas une augmentation de
l'activité solaire, l'activité du soleil
actuellement, il y a des une des faibles
variabilités et ça ne joue que pour au
niveau de de la terre que pour un diè de
degrés. Donc non, je ne crois pas. Il y
a pas il y a pas cette
une autre question pour Jean. Est-ce que
la géoingénierie
c'est une solution ?
Alors je vais essayer de dire ma réponse
est non. Alors pourquoi ? Je vais
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi. Je pense
que c'est principalement une raison
éthique.
Donc la géingénierie par exemple, ça
consisterait ça pourrait consister à
envoyer des aérosoles. En fait à chaque
grand volcan, il y a disons un
refroidissement qui dure à peu près
euh disons de ou 3 ans de quelques
dizaines de degrés. Donc l'idée une des
idées phare de la géoingénierie, c'est
qui est dont on parle le plus, c'est
justement de jouer les apprentis
volcanologues, c'estàd d'envoyer les
aérosoles
à une altitude d'une dizaine de
kilomètres et effectivement de disons
que ces aérosoles pourraient jouer le
rôle que jouent les aérosoles
volcaniques de de disons de de limiter
le réchauffement. Admettons que nous
alors il y a il y a deux aspects qui
sont qui sont il y a il y a le premier
aspect c'est qu'il y a il y a des
risques d'effets secondaires sur les
précipitations sur le cycle de l'ozone
qui sont non négligeables et non
maîtrisé. Donc euh disons si on
détériore si on effectivement si on
réussissait à limiter le réchauffement
climatique mais à détériorer d'autres
caractéristiques du climat ou ou de
l'environnement, ça ne serait pas
terrible.
surtout si on veut disons contrer le
l'augmentation du gaz carbonique et de
l'effet de serre et bien il faut
augmenter la dose chaque année he chaque
année il faudra envoyer de plus en plus
disons d'aérosol dans la stratosphère et
puis si dans 20 30 ans et bien pour une
raison quelconque géopolitique technique
technologique ou bien disons
simplement une guerre je dirais et bien
on est obligé d'arrêter cette cette
injection et bien les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui lui prendrait le
réchauffement d'un degré non pas en en
30 ans, 20 ou 30 ans comme on va le
faire mais plutôt en 3 ou 4 ans. Les
conséquences serent encore plus
terribles. C'est-à-dire que c'est d'un
égoïsme incroyable de la part de nos
générations de commencer à faire de la
gent ingénierie. c'est-à-dire de mettre
vraiment une épée de damoclè sur les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui par rapport enfin
si j'étais jeune aujourd'hui je me je me
disons je me révolterai contre l'idée de
la de la de de la géoingénierie pour
cette raison principalement éthique je
pense que c'est voilà donc après c'est
c'est la principale raison il y a aussi
ces risques d'effets secondaires. Il y a
d'autres méthodes qui sont envisagées
mais globalement si disons à titre en
tout cas personnel dans les les
scientifiques sont extrêmement
disons n'encourage pas en tout cas le GC
certainement mais je n'y crois vraiment
pas c'est reculer le le problème et
mettre vraiment des difficultés sur les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui encore plus on leur
demande déjà on leur demande de piéger
du non seulement on leur demande de
s'adapter à un réchauffement climatique
qui sera qui risque d'être non
négligeable Mais on leur demande déjà
d'être en mesure de pomper, d'extraire
une partie du surd de l'atmosphère. Vous
voyez déjà comment on est égoïste. Si en
plus on ajoute de la joie ingénierie et
bien c'est vraiment je dirais n'importe
quoi de la part de nos générations.
Il est 18h28 donc il nous reste il nous
reste 10 minutes parce que Jean doit
aller à l'opéra.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Est-ce que ça protège le climat l'opéra
? Est-ce que Est-ce que le
bah la culture, on peut parler de la
culture en général, je pense que je
crois beaucoup à ce lien entre la
démarche,
disons la la la démarche qui nous
conduit à respecter notre environnement.
C'est ce que nous essayons de faire à
travers et je dirais bien sûr la culture
se
je je crois que que disons on voit bien
d'ailleurs il y a il y a aussi bien sûr
t tous les tous ceux qui sont
attachés au aux cultures au disons des
des pays qui souffrent par exemple il y
a des populations d'aborigènes qui
souffrent peut-être plus de
l'environnement mais généralement je
pense que le développement culturel est
plutôt va plutôt en symbiose avec la
prise en compte de la réalité des
problèmes environnementaux, je je le
pense sincèrement et donc lire, se
cultiver, regarder autour de soi ce qui
se passe, c'est ça aussi la culture. Et
donc cette culture, elle nous permet, je
crois, de s'ouvrir sur le monde et je
pense que ça va plutôt main dans la main
que le contraire.
Euh, je vous tiens encore pendant que
vous avez la parole. Est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous conseiller trois livres
à lire
et nous laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations et ensuite on donnera
la parole à Pierre ? Alors, trois livres
à lire pour ça c'est Oui, ça c'était pas
bien sûr, on a bon disons avec Pierre,
on a écrit aussi un livre qui est plus
détaillé que celui-là qui s'appelle pour
éviter un chaos climatique et et
financier. Autrement, j'aimerais Bon,
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien plutôt les
livres qui qui sont porteurs d'espoir,
mais disons par rapport à ce qui nous
concerne
bon mais il y a il y en a peut-être bon
je n'ai pas vrai j'ai pas de titre en
tête mais je je disons j'aimerais bien
que à travers la lecture et bien il y a
une prise de conscience de de cette
réalité du réchauffement climatique des
solutions qui peuvent être mises en
œuvre ce mais bien sûr aussi une je le
redis peut-être une ouverture plus
général des jeunes vers vers
l'environnement en général. Mais je n'ai
pas de titre particulier dans ce cas-là.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
lire lire, s'intéresser à ce qui se
passe autour d'eux. C'est cela qui est
important
et puis et agir avec d'autres. Agir avec
d'autres pour faire bouger les choses.
Euh comme économiste, l'économie band,
je voudrais donner une autre raison de
d'accélérer et de se battre dans les
mois qui viennent pour gagner la
bataille du climat, c'est qu'il est très
probable qu'on va vers une nouvelle
crise financière. Euh on certains
journaux me présentent comme un des cinq
qui avait annoncé la crise financière.
En 2005, Dominique Schroscan se moquait
de moi. Donc il n'y avait aucun risque
de crise. Je Schroscan m'avait humilié
pendant 400 personnes pour dire je
m'inquiétais pour rien. Et 18 mois plus
tard, il y avait la crise des seulpagne
qui commençait. Et ça c'est la courbe de
la dette aux États-Unis. Je sais pas si
on la voit. La dette totale privée et
publique. L'an dernier, il a fallu 2580
milliards de dettes en plus.
Ça m'a cogn
2500. C'est-à-dire, c'est du jamais vu.
Si vous allez vous allez sur Flow of
Funds, vous tapez sur votre système
informatique préféré Flow of Funds et
tous les 3 mois, la réserve fédérale
montre la dette privée, la dette
publique. Voilà 2580 milliards. Donc
Donald Trump dit que grâce à lui, il y a
un peu de croissance, toujours la
croissance, la croissance. Mais pour
faire ça de croissance maintenant, il
faut ça de dette. C'est un peu comme si
votre voiture avait besoin de 3 L
d'huile tous les 200 m. Donc ça peut
péter n'importe quand. Le plus probable
et maintenant une majorité
d'économistes, c'est Bloomberg qui le
dit hein, qui explique que 300
économistes sont consultés qui pensent
que ça va péter l'année prochaine.
Donald Trump fait tout pour prolonger.
Il engueule la réserve fédérale pour
essayer que la bulle prolonge jusqu'au
après les élections présidentielles
américaines. Mais le plus probable,
c'est que ça va péter dans l'année qui
vient. Personne ne sait. Et le FMI nous
dit que la prochaine crise peut avoir
des conséquences 10 fois plus graves. Le
le FMI, le journal les échos qui cite le
FMI, la prochaine crise peut avoir des
conséquences 10 fois plus graves que en
2008. Donc tout ça nous pousse à dire
qu'il faut complètement changer de
modèle. Je remonte cette courbe parce
que la fin de la courbe est flippant. Ça
ça peut péter. Mais la bonne nouvelle,
c'est que pendant 30 ans, il n'y avait
pas eu aucune crise entre 1950 et
l'arrivée de Ronald Rean. Vous voyez que
la courbe était parfaitement euh stable.
Et pourquoi ? Pourquoi est-ce que
pendant 30 ans, il n'y avait pas besoin
de dette ? C'est parce qu'il y avait des
régulations sociales. La première chose
que fait Roosevelt quand avant même
Breton Hoods avant de prendre 3 semaines
pour reconstruire le système bancaire
mondial, c'est Philadelphie. Il y a une
photo magnifique. On voit Roosevelt qui
signe avec les autres. Un texte
splendide. Il n'y aura pas de paix
durable sans justice sociale. Le travail
humain n'est pas une marchandise qu'on
peut brader. On peut pas baisser les
salaires quand il y a trop de chômage.
La pauvreté est un danger pour la
prospérité de tous. Et le texte de
Philadelphie dit que dans chaque pays et
dans le commerce mondial, il faut des
règles sociales. C'est pas du pipo si
tous les hommes étaient des frères. Tous
ceux qui avaient connu la crise de 29
disent que dans chaque pays et dans le
commerce mondial, il faut des règles sur
le salaire minimum, sur le temps de
travail, sur les cotisations pour payer
la sécurité sociale. Et pendant 30 ans,
tant qu'on tenait bon sur Philadelphie,
ce qui allaient au salaire était correct
et on avait pas besoin de dette. Et puis
Ronald Rean arrive, on explique que tout
ça c'est de la foutise, c'est de du un
système soviétique et dans tous les
pays, on commence à précariser le marché
du travail et dans tous les pays, ce qui
va au salaire diminue. La courbe en
rouge, c'est pour les 15 pays les plus
importants de la planète. On voit que ce
qui va au salaire diminue chaque année
par rapport à ce qui va au bénéfice. Et
ce qu'on donne pas par le salaire, on le
donne par la dette. Et c'est comme ça
qu'on voit qu'on a besoin de toujours
plus de dette. Donc si j'ai montré cette
courbe, c'est pour dire premièrement la
question du climat en tant que tel, il y
a une urgence. On a plus quelques années
pour agir mais il y a un risque que la
la crise financière explose dans 6 mois
ou dans 8 mois et que de nouveau les
politiques oublient la question du
climat. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut se
dire nous à Bruxelles avec des copains
des ONG maintenant on se voit toutes les
semaines des élus de plusieurs bords
politiques, des ONG, des experts et on
s'est mis en mode commando, on veut
gagner dans les 6 mois qui viennent
parce qu'il y a vraiment un risque que
sur le climat ce soit trop tard et que
la crise financière nous fasse tout
bouffer. Mais la bonne nouvelle et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que la justice
sociale c'est la solution. Certains
voudraient nous dire que la justice
sociale c'est un luxe auquel il faut
renoncer mais tant qu'on tenait bon sur
la justice sociale pendant 30 ans
jusqu'à l'arrivée des libéraux pouvoir.
Tr bouquins. Trois bouquins et un
conseil. les trois bouquins, je suis Il
y a un bouquin qui est passionnant. Donc
le petit bouquin qu'on a fait avec Jean
et Anessel honnêtement est très
intéressant et j'ai zéro centimes de
droits d'auteur. Donc franchement tout
le monde nous dit qu'il est intéressant.
Il y a un bouquin je suis fatigué c'est
perdre la terre je crois qui c'est un
bouquin qui est traduit des de
l'américain qui montre comment les lobby
en tout comment en 79 on savait déjà
qu'il y avait un consensus de tous les
scientifiques sur la réalité du
dérèglement climatique sur quoi perdre
la terre. C'est vraiment passionnant.
C'est juste flippant de voir le poids
des lobby et je finis et je finis
là-dessus sur le le fait qu'il faut
vraiment un lobby citoyen. C'est
vraiment ce qui me réveille la nuit,
c'est comment est-ce qu'on on donne du
courage aux citoyens pour pousser à
l'action. Quand Nicolas Hul démissionne
il y a 1 an, il dit il y a une inertie
du pouvoir. Il dit "Ma relation avec
Emmanuel Macron est bonne humainement
mais manifestement ce gouvernement n'a
pas compris le problème climatique." Et
puis dit "Il y a des lobby qui ne
veulent pas qu'on agisse. Il y a des
gens qui veulent vendre du pétrole. Il y
a des gens qui veulent vendre des
voitures même si elles polluent." Voilà,
ils sont ils sont notés leur stockuption
dépendent. Voilà, donc face à ces lobby
qui bloquent toute évolution, je crois
qu'il faut qu'il a un lobby citoyen très
fort. Je le dis, cette campagne qui a
été lancée par les ONG, il faut vraiment
il faut vraiment qu'on soit un maximum
de gens à dire aux députés, aux
politiques, on arrête les discours et
maintenant on passe à l'action. C'est à
l'Europe d'inventer un nouveau modèle
beaucoup plus équilibré.
Et le bouquin, le conseil pour les
jeunes générations, c'était ça,
c'était passer à l'action parce il y a
de quoi déprimer et dans 10 ans, on se
dira on a été nul et on s'engueulera
entre nous. Par contre, une action
joyeuse. J'étais encore avec Adélaï l' 3
jours à Bell. Ça peut rendre vraiment
joyeux d'agir. [raclement de gorge]
Pierre, commence pas à me voler le micro
parce que tu sais que j'aime pas ça.
J'arrête.
Euh, un mot sur le nucléaire vous deux,
Jean. Le pour ou contre le nucléaire ?
Non, je je ne suis pas contre le
nucléaire puisque d'abord je suis depuis
51 ans au CEA, donc je n'y seraiis pas
si j'étais contre le nucléaire. Mais il
faut bien voir que bon le nucléaire a sa
place dans le mix énergétique mais je
crois beaucoup au développement des
renouvelables quand on se place à
l'échelle planétaire. Ça c'est bien
clair. Quand on regarde le système
énergétique à horizon 2050, on pourrait
avoir au moins 50 % de l'énergie. Quand
on parle de l'énergie, électricité, euh
disons électricité, mobilité et chaleur,
et bien euh il faut absolument disons au
niveau planétaire, c'est vraiment les
renouvelables qui sont je crois l'espoir
et le développement doit se faire. Le
nucléaire sera forcément limité mais je
ne suis pas du tout antinucléaire. Je je
crois j'ai dit qu'en France, j'étais
j'étais rapporteur de la loi sur au
titre du CES de la loi sur
disons la transition énergétique hein
pour la croissance verte et nous avons
dit dans dans cet avis avec
disons madameard donc ce rapport du CE
que disons il nous semblait équilibré
hein au niveau de la France c'est-à-dire
de faire une place au renouvelable et
voilà donc c'est c'est Mais je ne crois
pas non plus à la fin du nucléaire et le
nucléaire va continuer à se développer
dans certains pays. C'est très clair.
Pierre, 35 secondes sur le nucléaire.
Mon père était responsable de DF et nous
expliqué que le nucléaire était vraiment
pas cher, qu'il était vraiment sûr et
que les renouvelables étaient très chers
et n'étaient pas sûr. C'était il y a 30
ans et il avait raison. Mais maintenant
les courbes se sont inversées grâce à
tous ceux qui travaillent sur les
renouvelables. On a des le coût des
énergies renouvelables a beaucoup
baissé. Le coût du stockage des
renouvelables a beaucoup baissé. que ce
soit dans des batteries ou alors au
Danemark quand vous avez beaucoup de
d'énergie éolienne, on fait on utilise
l'électricité pour faire remonter l'eau
dans les barrages et on fera tomber
l'eau quand on en aura besoin. Et puis
on a encore vu il y a quelques jours
comment le le système en Angleterre EDF
vient d'annoncer que ça allait coûter
encore 2 milliards de plus et qu'on
allait prendre 2 ans. Donc je pense
qu'il faut
que ce qu'a dit Jean tout à l'heure
c'est l'essentiel c'est l'efficacité la
sobriété consommer beaucoup moins
d'énergie et que ce soit et pour
l'essentiel des énergies renouvelables.
Donc che8, c'était un peu court parce
que Jean doit aller à l'opéra.
Il y a plein de questions qui sont
restées en suspend. La communauté nous
le fait remarquer. Donc il va falloir
revenir.
D'accord. Euh euh et on vous souhaite
une excellente soirée et un bon courage.
J'ai le droit de dire mon espoir quand
même que cette convention citoyenne qui
commence dans quelques jours au conseil
économique social environnemental
qu'elle porte quand même j'espère je je
veux bien revenir dans quelques mois
avec j'espère des mots d'espoir parce
que les citoyens chacun d'entre nous on
a aussi notre rôle à jouer. C'est ça et
j'espère que c'est ce qui va sortir de
cette convention citoyenne pour le
climat.
Jean-Josel Pierre Larout. Merci,
merci Bertr.
Merci B.